[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them so
[Music]
you hate one guy so much
that you're gonna leave his app
and go to the other guy that you hate
and maybe even more maybe I I don't know
so it looks like Twitter is just gonna
be a show from now on because
everyone over there that was able to
jump ship jump ship because it was very
clear yesterday
that the new app from meta which is a
copycat I don't know if you caught this
but Elon Musk is suing Zuckerberg and
meta which is kind of hilarious I'll go
into that but this new act threads is
supposedly a copycat of Twitter I mean
what else are these apps besides
copycats of Twitter
to try to
compete and destroy Twitter I mean it's
not complicated
it really isn't like you're not gonna
come up with a new thing that people on
Twitter like that's not like Twitter
that's going to replace Twitter it has
to be something
to replace it because Elon destroyed it
right like that's the thing
now why does this matter in politics it
matters big time right now for messaging
a narrative
matters big time there there's going to
be a lull here which
I'm kind of glad this happened uh in
July of 2023 not July of 2024. to be
quite honest I'm really excited that
this happened now because all the chips
are going to move before the election
general election cycle starts
that's going to be what we don't know as
far as messaging and narrative and how
it's all going to work out right
so we'll we'll see we'll see how these
how these chips fall but it looks like
it's gonna fall now yesterday me and
Gabe Sanchez talked about what's an echo
chamber what's not I believe
and even contrary to popular belief I
believe that this is going to Echo
chamber the two sides now what that does
is this
it puts people on a more palatable
platform that's going to be left leaning
if you follow me there which is threads
it's gonna put less palpable content in
people on a right leaning
platform where No One's Gonna really
wanna go no one's I mean unless you
want to see Nazis and boobs
I'm serious oh my God I I showed you
yesterday the boobs are popping up on my
Twitter platform I'm not complaining no
don't get me wrong I'm not complaining
I'm just saying it's a lot of boobs a
lot of legs
and hey I I ladies keep making that
content I'm not complaining what I'm
saying is is that it's getting to where
it's just right Wingers it's people
rebutting and
and dunking right Wingers in the trash
and porn that's what Twitter is now as
it continues
that that it's just gonna be porn and
right Wingers
more and more people who are looking for
palatable content like sports and
entertainment movies they're gonna leave
that platform and go somewhere else
okay so think about that for a second
yes will each one be its own little Echo
Chamber Of course and we live in our own
Echo Chambers that's what the algorithms
really do that's what they're designed
to do
is to put us in a bubble on social media
that's the whole intention
I mean a algorithms are garbage in
garbage out right meaning if you put
garbage into it you're gonna get garbage
out and it's probably likely that
Twitter is feeding me a lot of boobs
because I stop and look at them
I'm not gonna lie I mean I'm not gonna
be I'm not gonna be I'm not gonna
lie to you you're the best audience in
the world I wouldn't lie to you of
course I take a second to make sure if
those are boobs or not on my Twitter
feed
I just want to make sure that's that's
all I'm trying to do and then I move on
but that's the thing is you put the
garbage in you get the garbage out right
so if I look at more boob picks the
algorithm's like oh
this guy likes boobs so to keep him on
Twitter longer we're going to make sure
there's more boobs in his timeline
it's pretty simple it's not it's not
rocket science Elon it's not
rocket science
but the idea that
Elon and Twitter oh man this guy
are gonna Sue
meta for copycatting someone get the
out of here man
Elon he is he really gonna he invented
Twitter is that what we're going to do
is is that how we're gonna act now is as
if Elon invented Twitter give me a
break
he did he invented electric cars I hear
that yeah he didn't meant Elon
didn't invent nothing
ever he just buys whatever he wants and
then claims it's his
it's what he does he acts like he's the
one that came up with the verified mark
check
he I
just go look at his tweets he acts like
he invented the verified check the
out of here man
and you're you think you're gonna be
successful at suing Mark Zuckerberg and
Facebook and meta
because they copycatted Twitter have you
seen parlor have you seen gab
have you seen true social give
me a break they all copy Twitter that's
the point
you stupid bastard
of course the reason why Elon is suing
threads or meta
is because it poses a real danger to him
right it didn't really pose a danger to
Twitter okay there's there's hundreds
and hundreds of millions of users on
Twitter daily active users and and yeah
it's gonna go down it's gonna tank and
it'll level off to some degree right
but the investors are the ones who are
going to get rid of Elon because he
this whole thing up
threads would not exist the right think
about this
a year ago well over a year ago Elon
Musk posted a tweet joking that he would
buy Twitter right he was he was he was
joking
and then his little in-cell army was
like Yeah by Twitter do it richest man
in the world you can do it
and so then he had to play out this
stupid joke
and here we are
where meta owned by Mark Zuckerberg I'm
not sure which one is Lex Luthor you
know what I mean a lot of people were
saying one is Lex Luthor and I I don't
know
I'm not really sure which ones likes
Luther or not
like these I don't even know if
Mark Zuckerberg is real anymore
I mean he he might just be a straight
Android I think that's where Ron
DeSantis got his Android suit from is
Mark Zuckerberg
you ever seen this guy
he's more robotic than Elon Musk but
these two Jesus Christ
and again maybe Lex Luthor and likes
Luther Jr
maybe maybe they're trying to fight over
maybe that's what the cage match is
about
maybe maybe that's what it should be do
a full-on cage match with tables chairs
and Bob wire bats and what we should do
is whoever wins gets the other one's
platform like they get they get it like
they just it's they just get it and then
do whatever they want with it they can
shut it down they can combine the two
whatever they want to do
foreign
's man he's really upset that Mark
Zuckerberg
out social media at him
and honestly it's of his own
fault here if Elon would have just hired
a CEO when he bought it a serious person
to run Twitter
and he stayed the off Twitter just
stayed the off of it didn't carry
in the stupid kitchen sink to take a
picture didn't didn't act like he's the
one who put up the money for Twitter
didn't set policy in cat turds comment
threads I'm not you that's a
thing
he was setting Twitter terms and
services in cat turds comment thread
that's listen to what I just said
that's the truth
what do you want from me again I don't
make this up I just tell
you how it is
hmm
but if he would have just hired
someone who could run Twitter
or just kept the team at Twitter and
found a CEO from within maybe Jack would
have remained the CEO I doubt it
Maybe
and if he would have just done that
there would be no threads today Mark
Zuckerberg would have no entry into the
market
because Mark Zuckerberg would say well
you can't really
you can't really compete with Twitter I
mean look at parlor gab true social
all these other social media sites to
try to copy it to be a right-wing
Twitter
they don't work they don't work and when
Twitter became a right-wing version of
itself
Mark Zuckerberg's like you goddamn right
we can make Twitter now use some
bitching right and I wonder
I wonder what the price tag is I wonder
how much and how long it took meta to
build threads that's what I want to know
like I want to know that exact number
and I want to know the exact amount of
time
think about that Elon Musk spent 44
billion dollars on Twitter
for Mark Zuckerberg to spend I don't
know
maybe 500 million maybe a billion I
don't know how much money how much money
is it cost to build to build threads and
how long three four five months with all
his engineers and probably all the
engineers he hired from Twitter that
that that Elon fired
ah what a dumb and now he's
gonna Sue because of copycats
again you say Tony why are you talking
about this you talk about politics this
has everything to do with politics folks
and because it has to do with messaging
and narrative yes we can't tweet our way
out of the mess that we're in
we can't the Nazis are now at our front
doorstep they're here
if you haven't been paying attention
Jesus Christ the moms of Liberty the
with casseroles the Mary KKK
the twatsys
have you seen this mom's a liberty
they're quoting Adolf Hitler the the
clan Karen Hood come on
the moms of Liberty there's a there's a
female Nazi group Neo-Nazi group out
there parading around like there for
Education I'm telling you they're on
your doorstep
this isn't hyperbole listen
they're right there in your board of
education's room he's talking into
microphones trying to get them to burn
books
Nazi propaganda they're quoting
Hitler on their monthly newsletter folks
the alarm Bells should be sounding
it's important that our messaging and
our narrative be one Direction
one piece of strategic outrage against
the right
and they're so been out of shape
over Ron DeSantis
losing oh it's glorious
Ron's doing such a horrible job
oh my God the right wing is in shambles
right now Now's the Time to strike Now's
the Time To Dance all over their grave
Ronda Santas can't catch he just can't
engage because he's a weirdo
so they they get his wife Casey out
there right and his wife Casey starts
Mama's for DeSantis it's like moms of
Liberty
just with the word DeSantis in it right
they're twatsys too
right they're they're with
casseroles
what I mean what do you want from me
they're the Mary KKK too like 2.0 type
right
they're Florida's mom moms of Liberty
but it's not it's not working very well
because Casey DeSantis is just as weird
as Ron well not quite not quite as weird
as Ron but she's pretty weird
and it doesn't play with Trump
supporters
that they're trying to get Casey
DeSantis to fill in Vermont Ron where
he's the weirdest
because you never you never saw Melania
filling in for Trump right they're like
oh what do you need a woman for Ron you
I mean that's what I think they're
thinking
why do you have to have your wife do it
for you Ron huh and that's what I mean
it's it's it's misogyny
but listen we have to politicize
everything folks you want to win
you want to win we have to smash Rhonda
Santas because here's the thing with Ron
here's the thing
the best part about this is that the
more Ron gets crushed here
the better it is that Trump's gonna be
the nominee and I hate to break the
truth to you but the easiest person in
the world to beat right now in a
national election is going to be Donald
Trump
I don't I don't know how more clear to
put it the easiest person to beat in a
general election is Donald Trump this
morning I watched a clip of Nikki Haley
embarrass herself
embarrass herself only telling you the
truth about Joe Biden and his record I'm
gonna show it to you today
Nikki Haley on Fox news on Fox and
Friends talking about how oh
Kamala Harris is the president
even Nikki Haley understands they cannot
run against Joe Biden's record they
can't
it's gonna be really tough with the
economy going the way that it's
going
they really thought man they really
thought the economy by now in July of
2023 was gonna be just they were
sure of it
they were positive that's what it was
going to be so much so that they were
trying to lie their way into making the
economy garbage
on Fox News
and even the moglodytes even the people
out there like oh Joe Budden's
destroying our country how are you
serious
that's what it sounds like when they
talk country
they're contributing to the good economy
because they're still going out to eat
they're still buying they're still
filling their gas tanks they're still
going to work they're still paying their
mortgages
a bunch of
listen you can't on one hand say Joe
Biden's destroying the economy and then
say our state economy here here in
Missouri or here in Georgia or here in
Florida are Republican economy is great
well you can't have a great economy in
your state and not contributed to the
great National economy I mean it would
be different if the national economy was
just garbage if our if our
national economy was just and your
red State economy was the opposite then
you could make a claim maybe you're
doing something different
but you're not you're not doing any
there's no difference in the numbers
from these red states where Republicans
have their thumb
on on the on on the legislator and the
governorships
there's no difference so you're part of
the national economy you're not an
outlier so you have to give the credit
to Joe Biden because he's the president
see how it works
and I mean if he gets the blame for yeah
I know
gas prices in the economy then he gets
the reward and that's what Nikki Haley
understands that's why Nikki Haley would
prefer to run against Kamala Harris
because Kamala Harris is not as popular
as Joe Biden
just the cold hard facts
if you don't like it don't come here to
listen because that's what you're gonna
get
but Nikki Haley even this morning
understands what is at stake in the
general election
no one no one is gonna beat Joe Biden
who is running as a republican there
ain't one not even Gavin
Newsom that could beat him in a primary
you notice that the RFK thing is kind of
fizzled right oh everyone excited about
RFK yeah he believes in gay frogs and
chemtrails and
I don't know kovitz fake vaccine gives
you 5G and it makes you magnetic or some
stupid I don't know what he
believes really honestly I don't think
he believes in that he's just
saying that because he's being paid
to say that just like Vivek
did you see that Vivek is at five
percent and he loves Trump oh he
loves Trump not gonna say anything
against Trump trump oh yeah they're
going to be running mate search some
I don't know the point is this it's
all
it's all stop looking at the
poll stop listen to the pundit
stop watching the goddamn mainstream
media stop listening to them stop
stop it
it's not for the
we don't need stupid ass commentary and
stupid ass punditry on we know
you're not dumb
you can see it right you can see it
Donald Trump is gonna be their nominee
because they're a cult
you see it I see it I've been seeing it
since December and January
you see it because you've been listening
to me Joe Biden is gonna be the
Democratic nominee Marianne Williamson
RFK or whoever the they try to get
to to be the nominee isn't gonna
matter he's gonna be the nominee you
dumb some it's gonna be Joe
Biden vs Donald Trump that's what it's
gonna be
no poll is going to convince you
otherwise no poll that you believe or
don't believe because you shouldn't
believe them
is gonna tell you what you
already know
that's one thing that is being made
clear about our country
clear it's crystal clear right now we're
not divided
we're not divided it's just they're
really loud
okay they're really loud but the country
is tired of that fat slob
they're sick of him
they're sick of thinking about him
they're sick of talking about him
they're sick of hearing about him
they're sick of him running
they're sick of him talking
they're sick of it they're sick of his
lies his nonsense they're sick
of the Republicans and Donald Trump
trying to rehash that happened
three years ago
Jesus Christ Rhonda Santa's supporters
and Donald Trump supporters when they
get in a room and they start fighting
they're fighting about March April and
May of 2020 over who created covid
I ain't you
Who had lockdowns who had the most
lockdowns who's responsible for the
lockdowns they talk about they're
arguing about that
you think average Americans give a good
God damn about who was responsible for
what lockdown that you did or didn't
have in March April May of 2020 you
don't think they want to go hey I'm
tired of talking about Tiger
King I want to move on
I watched Tiger King I watched the
second season I watched that third
season which is the best one I don't
want to talk about it anymore
Tiger King was the pandemic right that's
what I'm trying to do here
I want to watch something new
I want to know what the is gonna
come out soon
what we're gonna get to watch not what
we already watched three times
man
and that's why Donald Trump will lose
that's why he'll lose
have you heard one Republican one one
talk about what the they're gonna
do besides bigotry
one give me one I I I I I I
I'm sorry I'm wrong the vet this morning
I'll show you this clip Vivek says that
bureaucrats should only be able to be
bureaucrats for eight years he is such a
stupid oh my God he is a dumb
and vivec would probably come on this
show I almost guarantee you that dumb
son of a would come on this show
he would dare do it
he is a stupid
I'll show you the clip I think it's on
Fox news or some I don't know
this guy that's that that that is
running to be Trump's opponent
he's he's trying to be the number two in
the race they want him to be ahead of
DeSantis he's actually ahead of Mike
Pence
which is kind of crazy right and I guess
Mike Pence the other day tried to defend
him following the Constitution as the
vice president of the United States and
people were giving him all kinds of
but I mean vivec this nobody is pulling
a polling
ahead of Mike Pence the former vice
president
I think the fly on Mike Pence's
head is pulling ahead of him
oh boy what a Friday what a Friday we
got bonehead of the week Gabe Sanchez is
going to join us at the top of the hour
for bonehead of the week uh people are
asking if I can see the YouTube chat
today you goddamn right I can so here's
what we're gonna do when we come back
from the break we're gonna do shoot the
where you get to ask me some
questions and I'll answer some of the
questions that you have in the chat so
don't don't go anywhere because we're
gonna do shoot the after the break
so here's what I want you to do go ahead
and start putting in your
putting in your questions put some
questions mark in front of your question
so I can see that it's a question
because we got a lot of comments coming
in today not just from YouTube but
Facebook and twitch but I want to tell
you why we're talking about YouTube go
ahead and subscribe right now to the
Tony Michaels podcast right here on
YouTube it's free to hit subscribe do
not forget to hit that button we're
trying to get the 20. we're at uh 16 000
some change so get us to 20 000
subscribers spread it around spread the
love around also go follow us on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod and if you're on
threads get us at the Tony Michaels and
at I am Gabe Sanchez you can also watch
us on meta's Facebook you can watch it
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels just go
to facebook.com the Tony Michaels
I know I don't know if um they're gonna
let us broadcast the threads eventually
if they let us broadcast the threads I'm
gonna stop broadcasting to Twitter I'm
not gonna lie and if we get polls on
threads We're not gonna do the
bonehead of the week pull on Twitter
anymore either probably and what are you
gonna do it's it's gonna be dead over
there
his traffic just tanked tanked speaking
of traffic but not tanking going up
follow us on Twitch it's free to follow
us on Twitch you go to twitch.tv slash
the Tony Michaels you know twitch and
YouTube are kind of funny right
so on YouTube you subscribe for free
on Twitch you follow for free
then you can subscribe on Twitch which
costs some money
but it's also can be free on Twitch here
is how if you have an Amazon Prime
account you can get one free
subscription with that price you get one
free subscription through Amazon gaming
with your Prime account if you link your
Amazon Prime account and your Twitch
account you link them together
what happens is you get you can give us
that one free subscription that you get
with your Prime account there's
directions even it's really easy you
just go to the tonymichaels.com that's
the Tony michaels.com you'll find the
directions there it's the third link
down it says link Amazon and twitch just
click that it gives you all the
directions to do that it even gives you
the directions to re-subscribe because
you have to re-subscribe every month
it's really easy it takes like two
seconds
and we get two dollars well it's two
dollars and some change
every single month when you link your
Amazon Prime account and your Twitch
account and you subscribe to the Twitch
account with your Amazon Prime account
it's a free way to give us monetary
support So if you already have a Prime
account consider consider linking it
with a Twitch account and giving us that
one free subscription that you get with
Amazon gaming go to the tonymichaels.com
the directions are there thanks to our
great mod Mighty librarian she's a great
researcher she put together the
directions I linked to them they're
right there on the Tony michaels.com and
don't forget to go grab your merch
speaking of Ron DeSantis earlier and his
wife Casey Ron DeSantis can go
himself that's right and you go to
store.thetonymichaels.com and get you a
tank top it's it's getting warm out
there go to store.dtonymichaels.com
that's
store.thetonymichaels.com and check out
all your Rhonda Santos can go
himself merch that coffee mug I got the
coffee mug the coffee tastes great in
that coffee mug it really does don't go
anywhere we'll be right back we're
shooting this we're going to shoot the
get your questions in the chat
hurry up go go get them don't go
anywhere we'll be right back shoot the
right next
we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds this
is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
oh man we got the questions coming in
hot
they're coming in hot
[Music]
like bombs on here we're gonna shoot
this I'm gonna answer a few
questions you guys have a lot of good
questions this morning uh on this I'm
just trying to search up a few of these
seeing if we can get to as many as we
can before Gabe Sanchez joins us at the
top of the hour we got 30 minutes I do
this thing on patreon and really
honestly you should go to the Tony
michaels.com check out my patreon page
it's right there at the top just click
on the patreon go to the Tony
michaels.com click the patreon link or
you go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
I do an ask me anything I'll probably do
one this weekend where you come in for
30 minutes and I answer every single
question
that you ask now on the shoot this
here it's kind of an example of that
with the show it's kind of an example
um of how that works but I don't answer
every single one on the show because
there's so many
but on patreon I answer every single one
that you can ask within 30 minutes so go
to patreon.com Michaels or the Tony
michaels.com and check out patreon there
well let's shoot the a bit
see if we can get some of these uh uh
tawada to Tawanda I don't know
oh whoops uh can Republicans even spell
Rama Swami it's vivec that's my Vex rat
last name I don't see it very well so I
just say vivec because that's what
they're gonna say Vivek no they probably
can't spell it
they probably can't but it doesn't
matter because I believe now a lot of
Rhonda Santos uh shills on Twitter are
starting to come around to this
I've been saying this for months the
first time I heard vivec speak I was
like this guy's being paid by Trump to
run this is who Trump wants as his
opponent that's what my belief was it's
what it still is I believe that Donald
Trump is looking to get vivec in the
number two spot so that way Trump gets
to debate vivec only because we've got
another question about the debates here
now let me see if I can find it here
here it is it's from Robbie on YouTube
This is how many GOP candidates will
qualify for the first debate it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter the RNC is irrelevant
I know you don't think they are the only
relevancy they have is they'll they'll
have to nominate Donald Trump because of
the delegates that he'll have
but he pretty much controls them Hook
Line Sinker because they can't go
anywhere without him
and if they host a debate without him
it's not gonna get it's not they're not
gonna care because the only question
that's going to be raised is Donald
Trump this Donald Trump that and he's
not even going to be standing there
and it's going to be very obvious that
these stupid standing on stage
are trying to beat him
that's why he's not going to be there in
the first debate
Donald Trump is planning on that team
Trump is planning on that he's going to
have another event
now rather it's true or not he's gonna
claim he got way higher ratings and his
supporters are gonna believe him
and as they believe him the right wing
internet will believe them
no matter what Rhonda Santa's supporters
say the few of them it's going to be
glorious I I I don't know why we're not
so excited about this like I'm excited
about this I'm excited to watch them
beat each other up they're going
to destroy each other
your party is dead we just gotta watch
them keep digging the political grade
don't take the shovel out of their hands
so I believe that vivek's purpose
is to be the number two spot even if he
can get to where he's close to DeSantis
in the polls what Trump is going to do
is claim that vivec is his only opponent
and he will only debate Vivek and if
you've listened to vivec he will not he
will not attack Trump he won't do it
that's why that's the plan
that's the plan is to have Trump and the
number two vivec on stage debating
and vivec praising Trump on stage as
they debate
it's all rigged it's always been rigged
with him uh Lisa asked would would you
rather be in Missouri in humidity or in
Arizona in 115. I don't know
Missouri is humid as it's hot right
now it's hot yesterday was okay
man it's hot man I don't know I I'm I'm
probably used to humidity so I'd have to
probably say humidity because that's
just what I grew up with my whole life
so that's what that's the kind of heat I
know
so I'm not really sure Lisa I mean I'd
come to Arizona and try it out I'm not
saying I wouldn't but then you know
that's how it goes oh Linda brings up
tyt
okay all you tyt people who hate
me for knocking on tyt here you go here
you go I told you I wish you just
listened to me turn it off it's
trash Nina Turner's trash t-y-t
is trash Jank is trash and it's trash
they're trash they're grifting
trash folks that's all they're doing is
grifting stop watching that
stop it stop even if you like some of
their some of their contributors which I
do
I like some of their contributors
some of their contributors don't do this
if you didn't know
um tyt let go one of their trans
contributors and they spoke out against
them
because they're transphobes
and it it it they try to mask it and
hide it with this oh Trans athlete thing
and then they try to mask it Anna tries
to mask it with well I you're not really
a woman I'm a woman type
okay
I'm telling you it's grifting trash
don't listen to it don't watch it and
when you see it tell people it's
trash
and if you don't like me because I
attack the left tyt because they
attacked Aleppo this is me attacking the
left turn that off
turn it off
they're grifting you is that good enough
Linda
I know I called it I always call it well
that's why you come here
that's why everyone should come here to
be quite honest with you even if you
hate me
there's no one on the left talking like
this there's no one on the left doing
this kind of commentary that doesn't
exist
I keep telling you to find it for me no
one provides it yes there's people that
are close that are similar nothing like
this they just don't
um RC Elsie asked when will Tony and
Gabe meet in person that's a good
question I would imagine that the
biggest first opportunity was gonna be
the DNC next year we've considered to go
to the Democratic National Convention
I'd like to go to the Republican one too
why not L one with them in
front of their faces why not let's see
how tough they really are huh them
but we'll see we'll see maybe that'll
happen
uh Stanley says here on YouTube Tony at
some point will not turn on Trump or
keep getting his diet coke As Long As
Trump is paying not as legal bills NADA
will stay with him
and until he really gets it in his mind
that the only way for a shorter prison
sentence is to get a different lawyer
and turn on Trump and get out of his
orbit that's when NADA will turn on him
that's when he'll turn is when the heat
is so hot
and they're saying look man the only way
out of this is to get that
um oh someone adding to the question of
Tony and Gabe meeting will we will we
get to see the video of us meaning sure
why we'll record that we record
everything else so why wouldn't we
record that of course we would uh that
Sandy asked do you think Trump's Secret
Service detail will be stationed outside
of his jail cell this is a great
question Sandy I I know this seems
trivial and this is so far down the road
but I like this question
and the reason why I like this question
is because it gets you thinking about
what can and can't happen right
and it gets you to really start to think
that hey maybe just maybe one of these
days he'll be held accountable the way
we want him held accountable but right
now we need to focus on being his jury
right think about this
think about this
we need to focus on being Trump's jury
because that's truly what we are here we
are Trump's jury in 2024
and we are trying to convince all the
other jury members out there all the
other jury members out there that they
should find him guilty as charged as a
buffoon
and make sure that that make sure that
there's an adult in the White House in
Joe Biden and is our goal
so
I like the question Sandy because I I
don't I I clearly don't know this the
answer to it because we haven't gotten
there in our history maybe we will maybe
we won't
but we are Trump's jury we are Trump's
juries so just remember it doesn't
matter who's standing outside his jail
cell it doesn't matter if he goes to a
jail cell
we're the one that gets to decide
whether he's president or not and it
should be a knot
let's see oh Lisa asked who owns twitch
Amazon owns twitch
Amazon bought twitch several years ago
that's why when you use your Amazon
Prime account to link it to your Twitch
account that's why you get the one free
subscription because Amazon owns twitch
which is kind of weird because the
subscription on Twitch cost 4.99 so it's
five bucks right so get this
Amazon owns twitch when you link the two
together Amazon gives twitch five
dollars so they give themselves
essentially five bucks out of your Prime
account right okay that you pay for just
comes out of your subscription that you
get but twitch gets five dollars twitch
takes half
so they take two dollars and fifty cents
essentially right then twitch puts fees
on it that they charge you to be a
twitch streamer when you get your money
so it I I did the map and I think it's I
think
it's hard to really determine but I
think it's like two dollars and seven
cents
is what Amazon gives twitch which is
Amazon which they own and then they take
their port and then they take another
part and then they give us the rest it's
really weird but Amazon owns twitch
they've owned it for a while
twitch is a little different than
YouTube I know you're asking from
YouTube twitch is a little different
than YouTube
it's only a streaming service I mean you
can go back and watch the the streams
that are there or clips that are there
uh on the account but only for so long
right
only for so long so it's a little
different than like YouTube it's just a
streaming platform and a lot of it it
was originally done for video Gamers
where they're streaming video games and
playing and watching people play video
games but it's become a hotbed for
Content streaming over there other than
just video games and we're growing over
there we're growing over there and I I'm
glad to have everyone on Twitch and
listen if you don't have a Twitch
account you should set one up
you really should you should set one up
go over there
because there are other streamers over
there that stream live if you want to
stream the app works a little different
than YouTube it has a little more
functionality when you're watching live
on your cell phone uh but I you know
it's up to you but go check it out check
it out twitch ain't twitch ain't all
that bad there's some good streamers and
yeah a lot of times I'll um they call it
a raid so at the end of the show I'll
send my viewers if you were over there
viewing my show to another show or to
another place where you're going to get
liberal commentary it may be stuff I
agree with and maybe not but I'm just
trying to give you the ability to go
watch some other stuff right other than
the mainstream media them uh Brian
ask here on YouTube he says what do you
think of Mitch McConnell only focusing
on Vore States for the senate race well
mitchman kind of has to he's not going
to have the money nor is he gonna have
the the play Donald Trump is gonna get
to get to really bang up these Senate
races again that's why I say it's so
important that Donald Trump is their
nominee
right because they're going to follow
him meaning the Senate candidates and
all the house race candidates
are gonna be Trump candidates right
that's why Mitch McConnell's trying to
stack the deck in these states because
he has to hang on to whatever he can
hang on to right so that's that's the
most important thing now now it's likely
that the race will shift
and that they'll stick money more places
as the other candidates emerge
but they're gonna try to protect what
they can protect because they're gonna
lose with Trump folks they're gonna lose
again big time they were supposed to win
big in 2022 and they didn't because of
trump they were supposed to win in 2020
and they didn't because of trump in 2018
they lost because of trump they will
lose again in 24 because of trump and
really honestly once he is at the top of
the ticket that race is is very
important of course
to our democracy
but those down ballot races and getting
engaged in our democracy for those down
ballot races and getting turnout
to be against Trump and his allies on
these tickets is going to be super
important we're going to show the world
who we are and we are not Trump
very important
um Jan asks um
have you ever thought about visiting
Austria
Austria I mean I would go to Austria why
not
wow that's where Arnold Schwarzenegger
is from
sure I would visit there uh let's go
back to some comments here
let's see do we have any more
um well Cancun Cruz lose his seat it's a
good possibility
I'm not saying it can't happen
it's it's a good it's a good possibility
that that
Ted Cruz could lose that seat but it's
up to turnout again and it's up to us
engaging our democracy that's the most
important that's the most important part
let's see
see some other questions we got about 15
minutes left let's see if we can get
some more questions and usually I go on
a higher tangent here do you think
Michael will uh fight
do I think Maga will fight for their mob
boss Fatima says I think you're saying
is there going to be violence
I think if we would have experienced
violence I think it would have came with
the indictments now I guess the big
indictment will be in DC over January
6th right so that that'll be over their
their proud moment of overturning our
elections
right
so I I think if there is a moment in
time where we can expect violence from
Maga probably will be then won't be
during the election when he loses
it's gonna be like I'm telling you when
Trump if he is the nominee and we come
election night
and he loses big it's gonna be like a
wet fart in a white thong this Maga
movement
it really truly is the one thing that
will put
that will put them to rest it will take
the wind out of their sails if they
can't win now they're gonna claim ah the
Democrats cheated it was all cheating
but listen folks the more they do that
the worse it is for them
the worse it's going to get because
people went and voted over and over and
over again and if you keep telling the
people who voted against them that that
you're doing this you're not doing the
thing that you're you know you're doing
it's not gonna it's not gonna work it's
not gonna work it just isn't
we've seen this play out over the last
six years well close
we we've watched it
play out with 2018 with 2020 with 2022
and all those elections in between those
special elections after row was
overturned last year in Kansas where
Kansas came out the women in Kansas said
no you're not going to take our
right to Health Care away from us and
then turn around and vote for
Republicans the same people want to take
it away from them
it doesn't make any sense I know it's
weird
you're like that doesn't give me any
hope but it should it should give you
hope
and and the hope is is that people will
turn out when people are trying to strip
away their rights and I'm
telling you
if if you think that Donald Trump isn't
going to be the polar opposite
of Joe Biden in the general election
you're outside your mind
and he is going to be saying some wild
crazy the wildest craziest you
ever heard him say and I know you're
like Jesus Christ that's a high
more that guy's a lunatic but he's gonna
say it he's gonna say it out loud and
everyone in this country is going to go
chase that's Christ
are you kidding me and all his
supporters gonna yeah we agree with him
kind of sorta I mean it's uh yeah we
well yeah we're yeah whatever Trump
it's gonna be a weird situation
it's gonna be a weird time
let's see what else do we have any other
questions that we have in chat
let's see let's see let's see
uh
um and there's some more tyt questions
but I think I put that one to bid
uh Robbie asked again oh where where are
the boxes NADA took out of the tunnel
I I mean I guess we'll find that out
or maybe we won't maybe maybe we won't
find out where they are maybe that's the
point
right
maybe that's why Donald Trump keeps
freaking out about the presidential
records act he keeps talking about the
presidential records act as if this is
going to be a good defense
it's not
it really isn't it's not gonna work
I mean it's just not gonna be
a situation where he can he can lie his
way out of it in federal court
I mean they're gonna the prosecutors and
the judge are going to stick to what the
law is and I know everyone's worried
about Canon but folks it's not just
gonna be Canon here
there's gonna be other jurisdictions
there's appeals courts that are above
Canon that we've watched rebut her
already
in this same case with the special
master
so
don't get too concerned with all this
stuff especially with a trial because
like I keep telling you there's not
going to be a trial
um someone asked uh here on YouTube
would I ever make the trip out to LA of
course I would
of course I'd make the trip to I mean
I'd have to have a really good reason to
you know to pick up and fly out there
but I would go
absolutely
Mr Rich David says Tony are you afraid
you will turn into Biltmore
attacking the left woke no
no I'm not I'm not afraid of being Bill
Mark bilmar is a comedian you see Bill
Maher is a comedian that is that is uh
operated in the space of commentary for
many years
that that is that is the problem that we
have with a lot of this commentary space
where you have like um Jimmy Dore you
have Bill Murray you have Joe Rogan
who have at once appeared to be on the
lap at their comedians right
now comedians have had a tough time in
the last decade but really the last six
or eight years with the metoo movement
and more people saying hey yay probably
shouldn't say that you probably
shouldn't say that anymore you
should probably come up with a different
line you should probably use
different words to describe that
and they don't want to right so so as a
comedian they're like no you I've
made the money I'm gonna make I'm gonna
make the jokes I want to make because
the intention of Comedy is to offend
which to some extent the intent of
Comedy is to offend
but who you're offending is the most
important part of Comedy right now at
one point in Bill Maher's career that
Jimmy Dore Joe Rogan and some of these
other comedians who claim to be
commentators which Bill Maher is
probably the one that can stake his
claim as a commentator the most right
the problem that they have is that they
only have their comedy to back them
right I'm not a comedian never claim to
be a comedian I don't do stand-up you
guys might think some of the I say
is funny and it sounds funny but eyes
not a comedian I'm not joking around I'm
serious about narrative and
political politicizing issues I'm dead
serious about being a commentator okay
I don't go to stand up on the weekends
and then try to do commentary as my
second gig
it's not what I do that's what Joe Rogan
Bill Maher and others have done
and when they when they try to mix their
comedy in commentary right when they try
to pair it together and then when they
get in a tough spot and they're like oh
well I I wasn't actually commentating I
was just I was I'm a comedian I'm a
commit that was a joke see you're
supposed you are supposed to know the
difference between when I'm commentating
and when I'm being a comedian right
now that's what they want
so I don't have any fear of becoming
Bill Maher and when I say attack the
left I'm really just digging at the
people who hate that I attack tyt just
because I attack tyt them what what
are you gonna do what the are you
gonna do if I attack tyt wait wait are
you gonna go tell you you're gonna go
tell the media police are you
what are you gonna go tell on me I don't
give a go tell tyt maybe maybe they
would come on here and I could argue
with him and talk some sense
into him
but the problem is that you can't talk
sense into something that is a grift
machine that's why it's so difficult to
talk these manga idiots off a ledge
they keep giving Trump money and then
and Maga money
because they can't quit it's part of a
cult
and to some extent tyt in the grifting
aspect of it is a cult if you're
listening to Nina Turner listen to me if
you're listening to Nina Turner you're
like yeah the she says that all of
it makes sense you're stupid
you you are delusional is what you are
if you listen to Nina Turner Nina Turner
says that is just absolutely 100
she knows it's and
then she's like I used to be a state
representative and a state senator so I
know yeah and you should know that that
is a bunch of that you're
saying and it doesn't work like that our
system doesn't work like that our
government doesn't work like that it
just doesn't our our two-party system
doesn't work like that and and it's okay
if you don't want it to work like that
that's okay it's okay to not want it to
work like that but to pretend that it
does is really bone-headed it's
really bone-ended to pretend it works
one way when it doesn't because it
doesn't help it doesn't help our
democracy it doesn't help the situation
that we have in the country
wear shitloads of fascists are knocking
on the front door because you're saying
that people want to hear so that
you can get their money
that's not that that's that that's not
helping so when I say I'm attacking a
left they're supposed to be the left of
me right they're supposed to be I don't
know if they are and I don't give a
really I don't care if you're left of me
or writing me or Center I don't give a
listen I'm gonna be who I am that's
how it's going to be here on this show I
don't give a I don't even notice
that and really it's to my detriment
more than anything financially because I
I can say all kinds of that
would get all kinds of people here to
give me money but I don't I just tell
you the way that I see it
and tyt is trash
and to to your to finish off your
question uh Mr Mr Rich David is no I
don't have a fear of becoming Bill Maher
and maybe maybe there's become a day
where you guys are telling me hey man
hey man and you're playing back this
clip you know what I mean but I at this
point I don't see that because I'm not a
comedian I'm not a comedian I'm not
trying to do commentary just to say
to say and just to give you garbage
so you'll give me money right what I'm
trying to do is say it in a certain way
in a certain voice in a certain
direction with a certain strategic
outrage to create a national narrative
the right wing has done it for years it
works it's really hard for me to
convince the left of this like I've
tried my damnedest I've been on the
phone with people you guys know who
these people are if I said their names
they're on the phone when I'm trying to
convince them like look I understand
what you're saying I get it that there's
all the left doesn't have this and the
left doesn't have that and right has
this and Ryan has that I'm like yeah but
it started somewhere
and the left needs to stop talking over
people and stop talking Adam
that the left needs to talk with them
and just talk with them
just talk with people it doesn't matter
who the they are if they don't
agree with you fine whatever
just give them the truth
and don't try to act like you're
so goddamn smart and that you know
better than anyone else stop doing that
and tyt does that Bill Maher does
that the mainstream media does that they
all do that the right wing does it to be
quite honest with you and if the left
got their together and realized
that the majority of people believe
these sets of things these set of
principles and if you just stick to the
media of those set of principles you're
not going to have this where you
got Bill Martin talking about wokism
which is stupid it's dumb
walcism doesn't exist that that puts
Bill Maher being around to Santa's
supporter are you kidding me get the
out of here it's garbage so no I I
at this point in my career in this point
in time I don't have a fear becoming
Bill Maher but you know I could change I
could change I used to listen to Bill
Maher a lot when I was
when I was like ye little lad uh Gabe
Sanchez should be uh joining us soon
here uh someone asked um
what was the most recent movie I saw uh
the most recent movie I saw
was The Flash movie I went to the movie
theater and seen The Flash movie I'm not
going to give it away there's an Easter
egg in there that it was just it was so
delicious and if you like
Superman like if you like Superman right
like there's Batman there's Batman
Easter eggs in there which is pretty
cool but this one Superman Easter egg
that's in that movie oh my God
if you know anything about like all the
Superman or are possible Superman movies
and all that oh my God you're gonna
you're gonna your pants when you go
watch this movie it was totally worth it
just for that one and I got stoned
before it it's a thing we've been doing
we go get we get stoned before we go
watch the movies man it makes them
better I don't know I think it does
what do you want from me I'm just I told
you I'm gonna be honest with you I'm not
gonna you around all right uh
oh what one more question one more
question
rocket rod says whose Coke was it Don
Juniors all right so a lot of people
want it to be John Juniors Don Jr
apparently wants it to be Don Juniors
he's really upset about this he's like
that's not my Coke I mean I wish it was
so that I could claim it and get it back
but it's not my Coke they want it to be
Hunter Biden's Coke but hunter buying
one anywhere near the White House when
they found this listen apparently
this morning the reporting is is that
they found it in a place where there's
private tours like like um staffers and
stuff their family and friends come in
and staffers will give them to her off
hours and stuff I told you yesterday
I told you yesterday that this idea that
cocaine doesn't go in and out of the
White House is stupid that drugs
aren't walking in and out of the White
House as dumb as dog okay there's
plenty of drugs in the white house
there's plenty of drugs in every
government building in this country okay
it just happens people do drugs it is a
thing that we do as humans and if you
don't know that
your dumbest dog all right
everybody stick around I'm hoping we can
get Gabe Sanchez and get to the bonehead
of the week don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
right after this
what the is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
bone end of the week
[Music]
God damn there's a lot of comments today
holy moly there's a lot of comments
today trying to get Gabe Sanchez on here
I think he's still ramping up bone head
of the week let's see if we've got the
acids ready to go
let's check on them let's check on them
oh boy let's see what other news did we
have while I'm joking on that oh yeah
Marjorie Taylor green apparently uh got
booted from the freedom caucus
for calling Lauren bobert a little
I guess
and I mean
you know I want to be excited about this
I want I want to be like yay and all
that but really does the Freedom
caucus really mean anything anymore I
mean
it's kind of like when you got someone
called the moms for Liberty right
they're not for Liberty that's just in
the name to trick your ass
you know that right
they're not actually they're not
actually moms for Liberty they're not
for Liberty they're against it
Jesus Christ they're they're fascist
they're Nazis they're they're
quoting Hitler do you think Hitler was
like a a
an advocate for Liberty are you kidding
me come on man pluck your head out of
your ass and understand that that's all
a bunch of
it's like uh um
Casey DeSantis doing mama's mama's for
DeSantis as if if you're a mom and you
support the Santas somehow that's
somehow that's uh right like that's a
good thing come on give me a break give
me a break
but but the freedom caucus doesn't
really mean anything does it does it
really I don't think it does if that's
the case uh let me show you nah let's
see I think I've got uh some some
and I'll show you this clip of Nikki
Haley too while we're waiting
let me see if I can find them
so um apparently Marjorie Taylor greens
I think it was Patriot takes that had
this Marjorie Taylor Green's team
from their their her podcast what's it
what's it called Battleground oh yeah
remember we showed you the art where
she's got like the machine gun and she's
going to the Capitol I remember this ah
we showed it to you like last week
I think so I think in the last week yeah
it had to be last week we we weren't
even on this week because of uh
vacation the Independence Day
um but oh
uh here we go well
here's Laura Loomer you guys know I love
this psychopath oh Lord loomer's great
Lauren loomerman she is this she's a
lunatic and she goes after Rhonda santis
and she I mean she licks Trump's balls
like you wouldn't believe but here she
is apparently on Man patriot take says
this apparently she's on Steve Bend and
I haven't watched this clip but they're
talking about Marjorie Taylor green
which is the subject we're on so we
might as well listen just exposed last
week as you talked about on your show uh
McCarthy directing his big donors in
California to have fundraisers for
DeSantis I mean what the hell when is
when is Marjorie Taylor green going to
tell her best friend Kevin McCarthy to
endorse her friend Donald Trump if she's
so Maga as she claims
right I wanted a shot in there okay uh
Laura uh where do people where do people
go into your social media to get more of
this oh you can tell that makes that
makes Bannon really uncomfortable
doesn't it ah see this is what I'm
telling you when the sandwich eats
itself you know you yeah my God has made
themselves a sandwich oh it's
it's nasty the Flies don't even
want to eat it even Mike Pence's flies
like no thank you I'm good that's
disgusting but they're eating
each other the sandwich is eating
itself now that's the great part even
Steve Madden's like oh man I don't know
oh Jesus Christ oh man that's not good
for politics when they're attacking each
other so thanks uh the Patriot takes for
um giving this that man the wow
the engagement is way down on Twitter I
want to show you something here
I want to show you this this is wild
okay so this is Patriot takes uh this is
the post Patriot takes a Steve Banner
laughed after Laura Loomer took a shot
at Margaret Taylor green on the War Room
show and this was posted 21 minutes ago
okay now Patriot takes has a shitload of
of followers right let me see if I can
let's see if I can bring it up here
maybe come on come on you
yeah not so I'm gonna bring it up let's
see okay
480 000 almost a half million followers
right
let's see if I can go back go back nope
that's not what I want go forward there
we go Jesus Christ okay
480 000 followers on Twitter now this
doesn't have to do with this video
but look at this
usually Patriot takes on a video like
this has much more than
9400 Impressions now this says views but
it's not really views this is
Impressions this is how many times it
showed up in a feed right on the 15th
one that has retweeted this in 21
minutes
listen folks the engagement is way down
I mean it is tanked on Twitter when you
see a tweet like this
um I bet I could go let me see if I can
go to um
let me see you mango because I can't
bring up threads on the um on the
computer here
but let's let me um I don't want to lose
track of this Mars retailer green story
but I I'm just noticing this and this is
a
this is important stuff let me see if I
can find on
um
on threads which is the new app that's
competing because I got patret takes on
there let's see Patriot takes posted
this video
20 minutes ago
um they only have listen to this they
only have 3 800 followers on threads
right so 480
000 a half a million on Twitter okay
they only have 3 800 not 38 000 not 380
3800 that same video posts almost the
same amount of time has
it has eight likes now go back to this
one you're like eight likes that's not a
lot this has 61.
and the problem is no one's found
Patriot takes on thread yet
it's it's it's user based it's followers
it's content digesters haven't found
them they only got 3 800 followers on
threads and they're still they're still
getting a better ratio on threads with
those followers
and the reason why is because traffic on
Twitter is tanked it's tanked I mean
besides a bunch of Nazis and
boobs are people looking for boops which
is mostly the incel Nazis
evidently
but that's that's just the way of the
the world here that we're living in with
this uh this new situation with threats
and I hope we get
and I really hope we do get uh threads
on desktop okay here's what I was
looking for here Patriot takes has it
um it says picture takes djt and
Marjorie Taylor green forever hearts
hearts hearts because that's what
Marjorie Taylor Green's Battleground now
this is their her podcast account
um Twitter right and they just retweet
her and stuff which ours does the same
thing we've got a pod account we've got
someone who tweets over there and they
retweet us and I retweet them
um so we got a pot account you just go
to at Tony Michaels pod on Twitter we're
probably gonna do a thread account too
I've got an Instagram account with this
so I'll probably open a thread account
too
um but Marjorie Taylor green
let's see oh no that's not the one I
wanted
answered everyone what I was looking for
let's see and there's Kerry Lake
and you should follow Patriot takes over
on threads if you're on threads now or
if you're on Instagram go get you no
that's not do
go get you a
oh that's I want to go through that one
too yeah where is it where is it uh no
that's not it they really
ha
Marjorie tether green hates
hates here it is here's the Saga
in the um the Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert
uh little the thing
um Patriot takes us Marjorie Taylor
Green's podcast account responded to the
post about being kicked off the freedom
caucus by doubling down on calling Mark
Lowman Moore wrote bobert
yeah
a little because the Daily Mail
said Marjorie Taylor green kicked out of
her caucus it's not her caucus by the
way it's just the freedom caucus and
again it's the anti-freedom necophagus
because they name things the opposite of
what they truly are for
um for calling on Lauren bobert a quote
and backing Kevin McCarthy
Margaret David Green's podcast account
tags Community notes on Twitter and says
little
they're literally saying that Margie
taters greens I didn't call her a
I called her a little little
I mean she is kind of little bitching
she I mean it's not a lie I'm not I'm
not gonna die I mean
arm over it is a little what are
you gonna do
I would use a different word but
I don't know which word would you use
type it in the chat
ah but the Saga goes on and why does it
matter
why does it matter if if Marjorie Taylor
green is in the freedom caucus it
doesn't because the freedom caucus is
irrelevant just like Marjorie Taylor
Green in this piece of sludge
um Kimberly Guilfoyle here Marjorie
Taylor green is on Kimberly guilfoyle's
show
what's with her lips and her hair is she
real
is Kimberly Guilfoyle real I don't I
mean no I'm saying like I know that our
lives probably aren't real in the cheeks
and the the face is kind of there's a
lot of work done but I I don't know if
it's if it's AI or not let's watch and I
think Republicans need to always
remember that and never forget it and we
have to understand the enemy that we're
dealing with this isn't the party that
we should work with across the aisle
because you can't work with Communists
and you can't work with liars and you
can't work with cheaters we need to
treat them exactly how they are
you can't work with liars and you can't
work with cheaters like people who lie
about election and try to go overturn it
at the Capitol with a violent
Insurrection like that kind of thing you
mean is that is that what you're saying
oh my God
oh let me see let me check this here oh
wow
yeah yeah
I'm just checking um when
when Patriot takes uh
um
traffic level dropped and you can see it
it's crazy so here is let me show you
this
so
um here is 17 hours ago okay we'll zoom
in this is a picture of speaking of
Lauren bobert
she's here with a couple veterans but
she actually she actually voted against
veterans being exposed to toxic berm
pits as Patriot takes but this was 17
hours ago that Patriot takes post this
see they have 133 000 Impressions right
okay let's zoom out let's go up uh this
one that I just showed you has 154 000
let me zoom in 154 000 Impressions so
that's it's about the same here and that
was 8 16 hours ago okay now here here is
the RFK
um talking about
something on the trader TV News Network
it's got 137 000 that was 15 hours ago
so we're still in that same range look
here look here this one here only got 25
000 impressions
and then you go up to this one this one
only got 39 000 Impressions do you see
what I'm talking about look at here now
this one went back to 114
on this one
on that one
but if you go up it's down to 19 four
hours ago
15 three hours ago
28 three hours ago I mean and man that
the engagement is dropped and it's not
because Patriot take sucks right it
isn't because page something Patriot
takes did it's because of what Elon did
it's what Elon did
oh boy looks like Graham Gabe Sanchez
coming in here in just a second let's
see if we can um pull up these uh
bonehead assets all right I want to show
you that video of Nikki Haley too don't
let me forget that
I want to show you this Nikki Haley
thing
um where she's on Fox News admitting
admitting in my view that Joe Biden
can't be beat
you just can't
and I'm gonna show you what I mean by
that here in just a second
um here in just a second we're gonna get
that going I'm trying to upload the uh
the bonehead assets it'll only take me a
second here to do this live on air right
um but I think Nikki Haley believes just
like I believe that she knows you can't
run against Joe Biden's record uh let me
show you what I mean here
uh about that in this Nikki Haley clip
and I think
who had this clip oh yeah it was a
recount the recount had this clip it's
kind of few and far between right now on
these clips on Twitter uh let's see make
sure the volume's up okay here is um
here's Nikki Haley on who she's gonna
run against let's listen anyone is
better than president Kamala Harris
anyone what what did she say anyone's
better than com president Kamala Harris
Let's listen again anyone is better than
president Kamala Harris anyone I plan on
being that person that takes on Kamala
but I'll tell you right now every
Republican should be signing that this
is not the time to get personal this is
not the time to get Petty you mean
President Biden you mean
well I think it's president Harris
but what it really means
she's really horrible at this isn't she
so not only okay so I think there's a
couple things Nikki Haley and her team
are trying to do here they're like okay
we're definitely gonna lose all right so
we're definitely gonna lose so what we
got to do is figure out a way that Nikki
Haley can either be the Vice
Presidential nominee on Trump's ticket
or
or just say some really stupid to
get uh someone to pay attention like RFK
Junior like RFK Junior says some crazy
outlandish about gay frogs and
vaccines and 5G and whatever the hell
and and a quarter of the people who took
the vaccine are dying the wild
um we'll just say some crazy and
maybe she'll get noticed on social media
that'll be cool yeah well she got
noticed but not because she's smart
because she's dumb
and so I believe though
what Nikki Haley is trying to do because
I really do think that Nikki Haley and
her team are delusional and they think
they're going to win it usually happens
in political campaigns they're like look
it's really early we've got plenty of
time we can win some delegates in Iowa
we can go to New Hampshire and possibly
get we can get really close and then we
can no
no you're delusional you're not gonna
win okay you suck and it sucks to suck
Nikki Haley but what they're we're
operating on above is this delusion that
she can get enough delegates to go to
the convention to get on the first
ballot denomination it's a really stupid
idea but she thinks it's it's it's gonna
work and what what they're trying to do
is set up this narrative that you can't
you cannot run against Joe Biden's
record because yesterday we saw all the
news was the economy is great
they don't want it to be oh God they
don't want it to be once I got another
clip to show you on that they don't want
it to be great
let me show you and again it's on Fox
news of course I mean where else would
it be
um here is uh Brian breenburg co-hosted
the big money show what the are you
me who is this guy
Brian breenburg co-host the big money
show well this guy's an idiot listen to
what he says
I would I would listen if you're taking
Financial advice from Brian here
after what he says holy
listen to this garbage so you are seeing
some signs of cooling in the labor
market and that's important because the
president's going to get out today and
tout his 12 million 13 million jobs I
gotta tell you that's not telling the
whole story right now a lot of that is
filling in from the pandemic
oh oh so listen Brian here thinks that
the reason we have a good economy okay
is the pandemic that's the reason why I
mean it's you know it's July 2023 right
right
it's the pandemic's fault that we have a
good
you see what's happening on the right
wing do you see how they keep they
really they really wanted oh they want
so bad for the 2024 race to be about
covet and vaccines they want it and
lockdowns oh my God they want it so bad
they want that they would love if coven
had some outbreaks and left-wing States
locked down they would love it
the problem is is that most people in
the the laughlining states got
vaccinated see and there's not going to
be enough of an outbreak to do lockdowns
or any kind of mask mandates you
fools there haven't been lockdowns in
red States since May of 2020 we're
talking over three years
the oh my God
oh sorry I'm losing it um Gabe Sanchez
is finally here
um
and it looks like he got a haircut you
know yesterday showed up with a beard
and um
and whatever the hell those locks were
but today he's he's got a new do so
apparently he went and
visit his Barber Gabe Sanchez I'm glad
you got to join us it looks like you got
business in the front party in the back
for the week oh that's that's how I like
to run my life uh I mean look the only
reason I I have this uh this new do yeah
as it were is because I I I forget the
comment but I saw a comment on
um on threads and they said basically
wait wait you're talking about the app
threads not actual threads yes not
actual threads I'm talking about this is
gonna get confusing you know what I mean
yeah I know I know uh it really should
they really should have called it
something different I know they Workshop
this thing but you know that's what it
is it is what it's gonna do right anyway
uh so somebody I don't remember who it
was I saw a comment yesterday while I
was like in between uh errands and they
said if you really went to the barber
or if you're going to cut the locks or
whatever it is get a mullet so I said
you know what that's a really good idea
so I straight up went to the barber we
did a die job because as you saw
yesterday it was a little bit gray right
so you know I had him do me a little
touch up you know that's definitely
there's definitely not a wig is what
you're saying no definitely no way I
definitely got it you know I got a
blowout in the front here I got
a blowout and then they just they lined
me up real nice all right that's um
pretty sweet that's a pretty sweet dude
just saying they don't they don't make
them like they used to
and I got a a big big tip to my barber
uh sick of it says on uh YouTube Joe
Dirt Sanchez
who's that guy with the last name
Sanchez you know I honestly do I I do
kind of uh feel bad that
that
our boy
is unable to see me in my form when he
says you mean said my name yeah I'm you
know I'm just thinking I just took a
moment to really take in him narrating
that you know that guy with the last
name Sanchez and I was just thinking
right now man it would be amazing if Seb
was able to see me right in my
my full form
the moment for a while are you gonna
you're gonna go to a different weekend
you know as they say it's the freaking
weekend
so why not you know I
I I live it up this weekend and then
maybe by Monday it's back to business
maybe it's party in the front business
in the back not sure yet TBD we'll see
what my barber can do maybe I gotta get
extensions in the Front Gotta trim up
you know I don't know who knows so maybe
surprise us on uh on Monday is that what
you're saying I'm just saying well you
never know apparently it's pride month
again did you know that so you could go
you could get your hair colored is it is
it Maga pride month well you know I I
I'm not sure if they mean like they're
proud of being Mega or Mega's proud like
mag is gay I'm not really sure what they
mean yet because you know the word pride
really with them right
yeah you print the word pride on
anything they get yeah but they
they're proud they have proud boys wow
proud soy boys right right I get it I
get it and and they're proud you know
and they have white pride right but
understand but it it just it seems weird
when Steve Bannon says this right listen
and this is from Patriot takes two it
says I'm at his Trader TV News Network
War Room listen to what he says about
pride month remember this is pride month
as far as uh Maga goes proud and proud
we're proud of the United States of
America we're proud of our national
anthem we are proud of our flag we're
proud of Old Glory okay we're proud of
all of it
holy Glory we're proud of Old Glory what
wasn't last month like
um
I don't know I believe last last month
it was flag month yeah it was flag month
there was like
um gun month or veterans something gun
month there's a gun month I mean no Tony
there's months for everything
every day's gotten multiple holidays now
every month God damn celebration hang on
I got breaking I got breaking news uh
you remember the Walmart shooter down in
Texas yes I did I just got a
notification a moment ago about that
yeah so a lot of bringing a lot of Life
senses uh Mueller she wrote has it here
from The Washington Post breaking Texas
Walmart shoes sentenced to 90
consecutive life sentences
holy
um this guy
is not going to get out of prison
anytime soon how old is he he's
22. no no he enjoy injured
22.23. how old is this guy this guy
can't be that old Jesus Christ
I mean you're talking
he's 24. God damn yeah 2019 uh this was
in this was in El Paso right and that
where the Walmart was yeah yeah
now I I remember because we covered uh
him doing the shooting at Walmart
because uh he targeted
Latinos in the no no no no no no this is
20 this is a 2019 shooting was it really
this is
no there's the other there's Buffalo you
think oh yes
you know what happens you know what
happens in this country they all just
kind of bleed together yeah when it
happened so often the reason it
used to be in this country like
something would happen and it would be
months before we'd have another school
shooting or mass shooting right right so
days you're giving us days I'd give it
hours I mean
hours yeah but there was there was
mention of El Paso after you've already
happened because there was the whole oh
people were bringing up past shootings
that happened in the state oh yeah
because there was a question of Abbott
and Ted Cruz and that's why it probably
sounds familiar is because it was
mentioned during that time and again was
one of those examples of like we've had
multiple shootings in the last handful
of years in our state alone and you guys
the Republicans have done nothing about
it and every time it happens all you say
is thoughts and prayers there's no
policy changes there's no effort going
forward you barely care about mental
health even though you you blame and
Gaslight everyone to say oh it's it's
mental health it's clearly a mental
health problem it's not the guns it's
it's the people the people are what kill
people guns don't kill people people
kill people
and despite all the stuff they don't
actually wanna
invest their time or their effort or
their actual empathy into changing so
that this doesn't happen again and what
we see is that it happens again and
again and again and again and I'm sure
the Republicans if they do make comment
about this they're going to say this guy
was was found guilty and you know thank
God that we brought Justice
it's almost like we could prevent this
very thing from happening if we put laws
in place or we put regulations in place
or we prevented giving anyone who's
anyone a gun and having open carry laws
it's almost like if we did things up
front to prevent
any sort of incident happening much like
Health Care you know it's preventative
care if you were to do things up front
you could prevent long-term or more
costly
things both not you know not just
Financial costs but emotional costs
right so it's crazy and they don't
understand how I don't know
government or people work in general
here's a good example I was talking
about vivec earlier because I I actually
think vivec you know now that now that
we're getting to the nitty-gritty
because someone was asking about the um
the Republican debates I mean you know
that's a good point I think I think
Trump's goal is to just debate vivec
that's like his goal because being like
that's a good point right Donald Trump
makes great points I don't have any
other comments what about your policy
man in the world yeah they're like
they're like what about your policy you
know that is a very good question and I
don't think I have a better policy than
Donald Trump right here I think what he
said and they're like sir he just said
that he wanted to bomb these countries
and I couldn't agree more I mean who who
would win that who wouldn't want to bomb
who who who who
wouldn't do those things yeah I'm gonna
nuke a hurricane of course that makes
sense these things make sense well
here's the Vic on Fox Business which is
oh man you talk about you talk
about an oxymoron Fox Business here he
is and he's going to talk about
bureaucracy in government
holy these people are dumber than
dog and it just keeps getting
Dumber listen despite when these
agencies don't deliver I'm thinking of
not only the FAA but also Department of
Education we we spent 200 billion
dollars on K-12 and covered relief and
this test scores just keep going down
when when agencies don't deliver is
there a way to make the government we
pay for accountable
the answer David is we need a president
and that's what I'm going to be who is
willing to shut those failing agencies
down I will shut down the U.S Department
of Education on strong constitutional
Authority I have a clear plan to lay off
over 75 percent of the federal employees
usually Republican presidents have been
told that Civil Service protections for
the federal bureaucrats would stop you
from doing that turns out I've actually
read the law Civil Service protections
only apply to individual firings to
protect against politicization they do
not apply to mass firings and mass
firings are exactly what I'm bringing to
Washington DC and my presidents that
would be that's exactly what you should
do vivec is get out there and tell
people that 75 percent of our government
is going to be gone so all that's you
know what's crazy about this do you know
who who relies on government more
than than anyone
is the rich the rich relies on
government more you know how they rely
on government more the state department
for instance does a lot of diplomatic
work to protect the richest business
interest not just here but all around
the world they work their asses off to
make sure that the rich in this country
benefit from our policies that we have
to make friends so that they can
sell their goods and services overseas
this is ridiculous it's
bone-headed it's stupid even at its core
imagine imagine just imagine
the how you're gonna get mail if
vivec lays off 75 well Tony you have to
remember that these are the same people
like Elon Musk who believe that they can
fire up to 80 90 of a company and still
believe that I can run as efficiently if
not more efficient than it was before
these people these Libertarians these
Republicans believe
yeah it we're just gonna fire all
these people right
they must be leftists they must they
must be they must be but you know for
these people who love to complain about
the fear of ai ai taking these jobs or
minorities or immigrants taking our jobs
or whatever might be
what's going to happen what's going to
happen if they lay off the people that
are already employed these white people
these proud Americans who live on these
government jobs and have these
government pensions this nice Health
Care
what's going to happen when they get
laid off are they gonna defend the
um
vivec and are they gonna are they gonna
defend and simp for the Republicans as
they get laid off as they as they have
no severance package they get kicked to
the curb do they hold their items and
look back and say
damn right thank goodness vivec was in
charge like are they are they honestly
going to look back and say that was a
good thing that you fired me because now
I'm gonna pull myself on my bootstraps
and have to now rely on a government
program that you Republicans have
decided to completely demolish and take
away from me so I guess I will be
homeless and now I will have to complain
about how these homeless people like
myself are on the street and they can't
do anything I'm just going to become a
drug addict I'm going to be
panhandling for money
it's insane it is completely insane that
these people will happily get on their
knees and like a little boy say oh
please sir may I have another and get
their taken from them well you know
what's funny about this because Cindy
brings up this point so so rich people
at the very top of the list that benefit
from our bureaucracy and the next is red
states that benefit from our bureaucracy
and it's normally it's normally the
people who are living in the welfare
state in the red states that the federal
government supports in those red States
now the next on the list you won't
believe this when I tell you this it's
American farmers that rely on federal
aid did you know that oh my God yeah
American farmers yeah I do know the way
that we have subsidized our it's called
the farm bill it's called the it's
called the farm bill and you know
originally when they did the farm bill
it was good for the country like it
helped the country and I'll tell you
that the farmers at the time were like
bring on the socialism baby we love
socialism we're Farmers we want the
government to buy our product
because no one else would because no one
else had the money to buy it so the
government bought it and then put it
into the market and then sold it and
gave food stamps so other people could
buy it it worked out great like hey
we'll pay you to grow the food and then
we'll give you the money to buy the food
it's the farm bill it works it's worked
for a long time in this country but you
know that's the other people that live
off the bureaucracy and it's hilarious
it's hilarious when you watch these
morons and I'm not talking about
beveck or Trump but these people who
support them not only voting their own
interests but their rhetoric is against
themselves against themselves in their
own interest why are you puking
up this stuff that is against your own
self-interest it's because they're a
cult they're a cult they're right-wing
cult and Vivek is right there taking
advantage of them so congratulations the
the Vic you bonehead and to
think to think that it's a good idea to
get rid of our bureaucracy
and to just just bottleneck government
like why it's almost it's almost as dumb
as when I hear
uh Cornell West say
there was a there was a a caller who who
called in to C-SPAN and asked the
question of like look I I'm an
independent
and I don't want this this group of
fascists to take over and strip away
these rights but I'm also not completely
sold on the Democratic Party
but in terms of the lesser of two evils
I'd rather go with the party that has a
substantial
you know audience and and support and
then Cornell West went on this whole
tangent it's like long-winded answer
about how well we got to identify the
problems and you know in order to change
we can't bind to the system and it's
like it's that same mentality
of well we'll we'll go with the third
party as it is with this vivex you know
running and and who's who's that who's
he actually running for and with and
supporting all the stuff and and who
these Republicans are supporting despite
the fact that they in their face
and they eat it up
but when I hear these arguments I'm like
how dumb are you
to to buy into that crap
how dumb do you have to be to say oh you
know what I'm gonna throw away my vote
or I'm gonna toss it this way and give
it to this person despite the fact that
the very thing they're planning to do is
going to go against your very
self-interest and your well-being you
will be worse off
if this person is in office
it's as simple as that
I mean and again again I say again and
again and again you you got to a
two-party system here and you got two
you got two choices and it's gonna be
Joe Biden
and Donald Trump that's gonna be your
choice maybe maybe around DeSantis not
really not really it's not really going
to be around
he was crying last night it's not gonna
be around us
he was what he was did you not see that
video he's crying he's like crying
he didn't get his afternoon I'd send it
before we go to bonehead come on I Gotta
Have This I Gotta Have this all right by
the way I need to I need to check to see
I I didn't really check
um who are oh you don't know who the DM
and the AC are no no I have no I think
you'll like who the AC is it's kind of
like a couple I didn't put her in with
him I just put him okay okay I got you
now I follow no yeah yeah yeah okay okay
I got you all right so so Rhonda what
was he crying over he was on a he was on
Fox News and was basically called out
for uh not being a good candidate
um there's also more to it I almost I
mean I almost put his wife on on
bonehead of the week for The Mamas for
DeSantis thing which I could not stop
laughing about last night it's hilarious
it's hilarious but I mean here's the
thing is that Rhonda Santa's
um crying that he's not the because
someone's like dude you're so did they
say you're not the good candidate or a
good candidate if I remember correctly
I'd have to watch the video again
because I watched last night but
basically makes the argument that he's
not a good candidate basically he's not
connecting with voters like he's doing
all this stuff and he's not connecting
why is he running because that's what
the Fox News host is making an argument
for he's like well what's the point of
you running if you can't get these
people to connect with you from a voter
level clearly your policies aren't
working or your proposed policies well I
mean because he just says woke what what
are you gonna do woke
you know go broke lgbtq plus one yeah
that's that's what he means
woke we're gonna attack the wokers the
wokers who's the Walkers you know the
wokers the people you hate
it's like the woman who is on the plane
and she's like I don't care she's
yelling about the guy that's in the back
which I guess was messing with her
because he was a Freemason or something
but it's a video where the woman is on
American Airlines I think he's the
flight and she goes and it went viral
this week well she's like oh my God yeah
and she's yelling and yelling and
yelling she's like you can't see the man
in the back there
all of that stuff goes crazy that's
that's what that reminds me of well
here's Ron on Fox News
who's this guy interviewing him is this
the is this the no he's not the
replacement because Jesse Waters got
Tucker Carlson's time slot So This Guy's
in in Tucker's time spot on this clip no
no no Jesse Waters well I know that but
what time was this on is what I'm asking
well that was 711 CT so that was Central
so 8 11 so 8 o'clock so it's the eight
o'clock hour
so maybe it's not official yet I just
remember reading that Jesse Watson maybe
he just maybe he just hasn't moved his
show over to that maybe yeah okay well
let's let's watch there's something
about you that's not connecting for
whatever reason not connecting with the
vote or whether or not I know what it is
I know what it is
um hear me out here maybe maybe I'm way
off my rocker he's a Nazi that's that's
probably it's a fair that could be your
assumption I'm just trying I'm trying to
be you know nice here and that's about
as nice I can be about Rhonda Santos
okay well let's listen to what Ron's
answer is be personality Donald Trump
says it's about loyalty Francis Suarez
says it's about your relationships and
it's not about those individuals so much
is I'm curious in the the analysis of
Ron DeSantis of why not yet is
connecting
well I think did you just see the news
today about uh the record fundraising
Hall we've had nobody's been able to
match that in the history of modern
presidents so we've got a huge amount of
support uh to be able to take the case
to the people we really haven't started
that yet there's something about you
that's not
listen
don't stop saying that about me what a
ain't listen what do you
think the head bombing thing is that he
does
you think honestly it's a it's a bit of
a tick he does the it's the what
I think it's his response when he gets
in because if you notice anytime he does
the head Bob there was the question when
he was he was in uh Japan he was in
Tokyo they asked him are you gonna run
he's like well if I do I'm gonna
when he was in Jerusalem
do you think it's he's low on pudding
like he runs on pudding so he's like see
and it's like a car when it's low on gas
like
I don't know if it's the pudding
if it's just the opportunity to be like
he doesn't have the opportunity to
spread his bigotry because somebody's
challenging him so they ask him I see
they ask him hey are you gonna run for
president and he goes well if I do I'll
decide and I'll tell you
bigotry is like glitching is that what
you're saying I think so like there's no
one in there to be like a echo chamber
sound right and so then when he was in
Jerusalem and they asked him about his
uh history and Guantanamo Bay about
torture right he was like oh well how
would he know that how would he remember
I'm pretty sure if you were being
tortured right you were
force-fed food and you were tortured
that you would remember the person who
was standing opposite you as they were
overseen if this whole thing and
laughing I mean it feels like that head
bombing would be burnt into your brain
yeah right you know what I mean
I'm pretty sure
but the bobble head is a tell on
whenever he doesn't know how to respond
when he's when his back against the is
against the wall Ron DeSantis will do
the bobble head right right he will you
know
honestly at this point I'm very curious
let's just see if I Google Honda Santa's
bobble head
toy
it exists it exists Excuse me give me
the give me the link let's show
everybody no don't don't hold down on us
here we want to see this thing does it
does it look like more of a human than
what then go to the video part play the
video it goes all the way I mean you can
go through the you can go through the
actual look at it here yeah yeah look in
here here we go okay
laughs look at the description okay
here's the description pesky Patriot
Governor Ron DeSantis bobblehead toy
it's seven inches tall uh resin action
figure gives ninjas of the Santa's not
sure where they're getting action
American flag makes a great gift idea
for Republicans this makes a great gift
idea for robot it's 22.99 by the way 47
ratings nobody review it anymore 4.5
Stars 45 Donald Trump 47 ratings next
president oh baby I'm just saying nobody
given another rating no one give it
another review do not do it keep it at
4.5 keep it at 47. that's all I'm saying
I'm not a conspiracy theorist but I'm
connecting the dots here's here's here's
him um next to Florida and looks great
gift idea
a side shot of bobblehead excellent
detail
Governor look they even put a red circle
around the bobble head oh in case
you didn't know it was a bobble head
based on the design and also the
description and the title it's a bobble
head it gives the it shows he's seven
inches tall for sure for sure two and a
half inches wide right but how is he
wearing high heels though well if it's
seven inches with the stand those are
the high heels that's the whole platform
I see here he is here he is in kind of a
live action you know he's an action
figure there's nothing like him no it
doesn't even look like around also looks
way Slimmer than him right if that's not
Rhonda santis is it here let me see if I
can how is this an action figure you
gotta click does that look like Ron
DeSantis nope
not even close who does that look like
can you can you take the the head shot
and put it in Google and see what it
gives you I could try but I think it's
gonna get it's gonna find me the actual
bobble head again right well I mean
maybe the van is trying to find it
imagine okay here's the let's see
[Music]
and painted man
yeah hand painted by some small child in
China can you look and see where it was
made oh yeah yeah hang on uh let's see
it's it's um it's the pesky Patriot
store who sells it yeah well are they
made in America I don't know it's sold
by okay
Liberty shirts
oh my God Liberty oh my God and it
shipped from Amazon door shut the
door
um hold on hold on
hope
did you Google search it wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait I got no I got something else
I got something else
I'm gonna get you this image yeah
hold on one second because it's it's
something
is something all right they make a whole
thing
yeah a whole group of them they have a
team of these action figures bobble
heads you mean the um yeah
God
oh this is great what the is this
okay now on the left who do we have Joe
Biden right right sleepy it's sleepy
sleepy then we got Donald Trump which
doesn't look like I mean the Joe Biden
looks more like Joe Biden than Donald
Trump looks like Donald Trump here
correct then you got Donald Trump who's
behind the wall I believe
I believe this guy here in the middle
that would be Canada that would be oh
Justin Trudeau yeah and he's got his
mouth open on his hands and knees
they're so sexual man they
sexualize everything they couldn't just
they couldn't just make the thing with
some phrase on it or they couldn't make
something
why are they what the because you
gotta give the ouchy to the fouchy baby
from behind oh that's what they want it
is very weird right Justin Trudeau got
the mouth open from the front and I'm
I'm I'm gonna go on on a limb here and
say that fauci's gotta open yeah right
in the back where you can give him an
ouchy right well I honestly think and
then they got Joe Biden in bed and then
they got you baby again they got him
sleeping in bed commander commander and
sleep it's I think it's listen I I don't
know what Steve Bannon was talking about
where this is Maga pride month but
honestly they sexualize everything that
they have sexualized their action
figures how how did they come to do that
they've got another one with Bernie
where it's just him sitting in the chair
but it's a bobble head which I'm like I
guess that's a burn but it's not I don't
know it's really weird it makes no sense
these people are not serious
I want this image
I knew I'm saving it it I don't
know what I want it for I'll probably
post on social media later today that's
weird I ain't gonna lie I
told you it's all sexualized action
figures
why are they that's a sweet video I'm
this I'm gonna say it um
if you're in small rats if you're in a
jet don't whatever you do don't
do the bobble head song don't do it
you should you should not do it small
rants but do you like it's just any
anything any person they don't like
instead of being like this person's bad
yeah and this is why they're bad they go
this is this person's bad now now
them right everyone has these t-shirts
for like Joe Biden or they're like
and and remember this is this is what
Maga says they're like oh man Joe Biden
can suck my dick oh man I'm gonna
Joe Biden oh man they say these things
and then and then you have to stop and
say wait whoa hey hold on a second sorry
what was that why are you why are you
telling Joe Biden to suck your dick
that's very weird let me tweet out a um
a photo here that I have
uh speaking of that I've been hanging on
to this one for a while
um and I just I wanted to who is it no
it's a it's a
um it's art on the back of like an SUV
right I gotta find it here okay there
you go it's probably what I imagine some
phrase similar to that I found it on the
internet okay uh it was it came off a
Reddit uh so I'm gonna tweet it here
real quick and then I'll show it to you
small rats listening I I knew it in
Arizona they give you the music too so
you can remix it you can pull that video
from there you know and great
but it's it's very weird man the
sexualization of of inanimate objects
it's crazy stuff you know when they go
to the hospital and the doctor says well
how'd that get in there and like oh I
don't know I fell off the couch in a
Villain Like sir you have a bobble head
of what appears to be sleepy Joe Biden
with the baseball cap on this one's
gonna hurt when we pull it out so this
is on the uh the alt-right
community on Reddit this is the a
picture of the back of this there we go
of this um what appears to be a great
Patriot says stop my flag I'll eat your
ass what what I mean I mean if you like
to get your ass eat then I'm gonna stop
if you're in for a little RJ action
totally fine why totally fine so wait
you're just saying I just gotta step on
the flag and you'll toss my salad is
that what you're saying I guess so if
that's what look I mean the people are
very very blunt about it they're like
You Touch My Flag I'll touch your butt
stop my flag I'll eat your ass okay like
very okay very like very weird why why
is that the first you went from you went
from this
to way over here you you said I hate
this person Joe Biden oh man I'm a
patriot too oh I'm gonna him so
good and at the same time they're like
man the LGBT community I hate them
but it's like what are you guys doing
here
clearly you have these repressed uh
feelings and there's no judgment if that
is how you feel and that's what you want
to do go out and do it be happy but
don't hate on a community for things
that are on the back of your
truck that make it seem very sus about
what your real feelings are the other
crazy thing about this stickers okay
yeah there's so much stuff some people
were asking about the nine line
apparel.com I'm not really sure where
the nine line comes from
like nine like nine
we could be oh no wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait one okay so so the the
The Punisher with the American flag how
they like appropriate The Punisher like
you understand that the Punisher
would hate you number one
number two this is on the back of a
Toyota okay now this is a Toyota 4Runner
I can see that it's a forerunner here
barely but you see that it's Toyota
4Runner now I'm not against Toyota I
think they make a forerunner's a good
vehicle actually they're really
good and they last forever and nine line
by the way yeah nine line yeah is a
Medevac
um recently they've met event what does
that have to do with start because well
according according to the website I
don't I don't know but according to the
website it says recently we have been
asked why our company's called Nine line
apparel this is why we are nine line
nine line is a military term that
medevacs use for calling in a combat
injury
after you eat someone's ass I guess so
such a stressful and sometimes hectic
situation when you're eating someone's
ass nine line is the best way to calmly
and accurately report that a soldier
needs medical attention
yes it is very important that the
information needed is communicated
clearly to ensure that the soldier gets
the care that he or she needs in a
timely manner when they're eating
someone's ass apparently it's important
steps to make sure that this procedure
is handled correctly when eating
someone's ass
reading from their website right now I
just read the first paragraph and each
one is so General but also kind of
specific about eating someone's ass it
really is seems weird it's weird it's
weird it's weird
but hey man if that's what you're into
that's what you're into
it well and you know I want to point out
that this person claims on the back of
their card to be an Air Force veteran
they have several several art things
that they've apparently bought from nine
line apparel here maybe they are nine
lines on the back maybe this is the
owner of maybe this
maybe it's the only person that actually
bought something from nine line apparel
it could be which is also funny because
yeah I know what we're going to point
out is Toyota Toyota
you can't know that it's Toyota right
I'm like I'm like look
I'm like look Toyota's made in America
almost all of them that are here are all
made here and there most of them are
made in American factories in red States
Believe It or Not which is crazy stuff I
know that Toyota plants are in red
States oh my God you freaked the
out and Toyo is a good car I'm not
knocking Toyota I I've owned Toyota's my
family's own Toyotas the Forerunner is a
good vehicle I I would own another
Toyota it's just funny how this is
someone's ass over well I mean they
would they would like whoa whoa hey
don't call my Toyota Un-American are all
all tongue punch your fart box
[Laughter]
but I also have to ask the question
which is what is
like what is the flag is it this flag is
it someone stomping their glass like
stop my my flag on the glass Ollie your
ass like is that the part that I'm
supposed to be filling in here is it
just any flag is it their specific flag
or is it this flag that's on the back of
this Forerunner I don't know and I don't
know how many ways we can say eat your
ass but I like tongue
tongue punch your fart box that's the
best one that's the best way to say eat
your asses tongue punch your fart box so
uh small rats and get your um time stamp
out maybe you could put that one on the
Rhonda santis I don't know maybe it'll
work out
I started bone of the week
be right back when we move back bonehead
of the week right after this
what the is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slam gems skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
here's Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
bonehead of the week where we stomp on
their Flags
and they tongue punch our Park boxes
they're weird they're weird as what
are you gonna do I don't know what else
to tell you it ain't my problem it ain't
my fault it ain't my problem is it Gabe
Sanchez
not my problem
uh bonehead of the week who do we got
this week for bonehead of the week we
got some contenders yeah across the
board there was one I had no idea why
you put them on here no clue I had no
clue but we're gonna find out we're
gonna find out well it's the Glenn young
oh the governor going again I I didn't I
you know I haven't been keeping up with
a lot of news I was kind of off and I
was out of pocket a lot like I was
intentionally in Flags I guess wow it's
not going to well you know hey if you're
gonna do that other thing I'm gonna
stomp on a lot of flags I'm gonna run
around just put my feet all over
your
I I didn't put my feet on Eddie Murphy's
couch that's what I'm thinking of
yo couch your couch yeah put my
feet on Eddie Murphy's couch
that's what I'm thinking of no I didn't
put my feet on his flag he's gonna eat
my ass yeah I put my feet on his leg
what the you gonna do what the
you gonna do oh my God so Glenn yonkin
was on the bone of the week why is Glenn
youngin on the bone of the week did you
put a link in there yeah I did so it
turns out that our uh
our Virginia governor yeah Glenn young
don't say our Nance you know I I mean it
in the most general of terms
okay
um well uh so he secretly removed a
suicide prevention resources for lgbtq
youth uh from a State website and he did
so after facing backlash from Maga
influences telling him to remove
resources again this is the same group
of people who are like cancel culture
isn't real we don't cancel people it's
only the left that does it wait wait did
they think that they think their The
Suicide Prevention resources was part of
pride month or something is that what
they thought or what it's quite possible
that these people thought that they were
converting people to say oh you're gay
Now kill yourself uh or don't kill
yourself or whatever that's what they
wanted it feels like that's what they
want is these people not to exist and
unaliving themselves sounds like what
Glenn Junkin wants them to do which is
not unlike the Republican Party we've
seen it you know this is right upstairs
their brand this is on brand for the
Republicans
but it says you know according to this
Washington Post article it says within
hours of an inquiry from the daily wire
a dozen resources including a live chat
online support for a group of teens were
removed from the State Health Department
website at the direction of the cabinet
level agency according to emails
obtained under the state's open record
laws the presence of their materials and
their subsequent disappearance on May
31st generated two headlines in a flurry
of online reaction from conservative
readers of the outlet co-found
co-founded by right-wing commentator Ben
Shapiro the decision elicited concern
from department leaders who had not been
consulted and began emailing their
higher ups asking why does it happen
again
so it it and this is also not the first
time this has happened at least three
times in the year and a half that he's
taken office to remove information from
the website without consulting anyone
who is of of expert in the subjects
according to records he's stripping
Public Health Resource on abortions
sexual health and pregnancy among other
issues and it's almost it's almost like
it matters
who is the governor in in a state it's
almost like it's almost like Republicans
people's lives rely on it it's almost
like I mean it's crazy how Republicans
will strip away the basic the basic
resources the bare necessity for a group
that claims to be pro-life save the
children save the children but those
those gay ones don't give them resources
they are full humans they're real people
they don't believe that they should be
provided the same prevention resources
and health care that a straight person
or at least a non-lgbtq plus person
should have
that's what it comes down to so when
Republicans say ah we're pro-life really
because it seems like you're okay with
certain lives not living you're okay
with certain lives ending
and the fact that you're unwilling to
protect those children those younger
it's an lgbtq plus youth Suicide
Prevention and and Tony you might wonder
why do we have such a program out there
especially for a specific group of
people well I don't know it might be
because that very group of people who
complained about this suicide prevention
program are the ones who are threatening
those Lives who are who are harassing
verbally physically assaulting these
people because they don't believe that
they actually exist because the
Republican Party says no no no you're
not straight you're not white you're not
rich you're not this you're not that you
don't count as a real person
and so you know assuming that's what you
yeah that's what you experience every
single day of your life you hear that
non-stop heal on your on your on
your head to push you down and say
you're not real you don't exist you
don't matter you hear that again and
again and again if anyone heard those
things
they would certainly have those thoughts
in their mind
and God forbid we have a program
that helps communicate
everything that's going on to those
people who have those thoughts and say
hey here are the resources here's who
you can talk to here's how we can we can
help deal with this
so when they claim to be pro-life
they're pro-death their pro-death for
anyone who isn't white who isn't
straight who is in catholic christian
whatever it might be they don't care
about anyone else I mean they barely
care about their constituents they make
sure that everything that they pass is
going to benefit themselves as well as
their wealthy wealthy wealthy donors
you know what now that I'm thinking
about it and I'm looking at this picture
of Glenn young
this bigot in this
such a piece of trash this is the
bobblehead that Rhonda Santos they they
just resource they repurposed it they
were going to make it Glenn young
because remember Glenn youngin was going
to be their hero remember when he won
that that Governor's race like oh my God
this guy could be president
I don't think so I don't think so we
will never be president he will be a
one-term
Governor yep he'll be in this trash bin
of History so let's go to
um the other boneheads I'm really
surprised about who won here to be quite
honest with you I mean I shouldn't be
but I'm really surprised because Eli
Elon is it was it how far away was it
like less than 10 percentage points
between between two people Rick it was
rigged it was rigged um I'm really I'm
really surprised at who won but I
shouldn't be I guess but Elon
why is Elon on the list can you uh
provide me a link of what you want
because I I mean there's supposedly
something in the news I can't really
think of what it is
um of why he would be a bonehead um it's
almost like his his engagement tanked
his uh website that he paid 44 billion
is going into the dumpster
um it's barely hanging on by a thread no
pun intended
what the I tried I tried and I got
there or threads maybe it's threads it's
hanging on by uh obviously I'm trying to
find the response because there was the
letter that was doing I'm gonna sue you
it's hilarious that Elon Musk is
like I invented Twitter and you can't
copycat like who like what are you
talking about man there's there's true
social there's part of there's gab how
many other copycat there's uh what's the
what's there's hundreds of them
there's hundreds of these copycat
Twitter
I made a post yesterday that was about
this very thing and it said you know
Elon where did you make it on Twitter on
threads I put it on both
I was trying to remember yesterday last
night to post on to Blue Sky to be like
oh do I have anything Blue Sky what the
Jesus
last week man I know no one's on Blue
Sky and that's last week Hey listen
listen
have you noticed that the engagement on
now per capita if you want to say this
and it's per follower right like it's
you're following do you know have you
noticed that your engagement's much
higher on threads than it is on Twitter
like in my my engagement tanked on
Twitter I would it's almost like no
one's on Twitter or something it's
almost like it's a ghost town There's a
I think I saw I don't know if Kayla's in
the
it kills in the um
the the chat right now but I did see
that she posted like a tumbleweed
and she was like is it just me or are
people just not here right now they're
not there they're now now people are
going back to check to see if it's still
a thing I was just going back yesterday
it's still it's still open I was only I
was only yeah looks like it's still open
right I was only on Twitter yesterday to
cross post stuff but also I was there to
check in on Elon to see how he was
cooking if he was okay news but what
happened yesterday and I'm trying to
find a response but it doesn't really
matter you know it's funny you know it's
funny it's funny he he bought Twitter to
get rid of bots and that's like the only
thing on there now
remember that it was never about the
Bots it was never about just like just
like last week when Elon tried to say oh
it's because we're here Elon said we're
we're closing down the ability for
people who are not users of the app to
look at tweets
remember that yeah well I mean yeah and
even when you like text it an SMS
message or on iMessage or something like
that it didn't show a preview of the
Tweet you had to click on that you
just said twitter.com that was it right
so before Elon was the one who actually
changed that and said you know what I
don't want people to have to go to the
login screen I want people to be able to
interact with Twitter and then they can
they can sign up or they can log in I
want people to see the trending topics
page so they know what's going on he did
that change he made that change and then
he goes oh well we're locking it down
because we got people scraping our
first off if people really want to take
stuff if they want to take stuff from
Twitter they're going to do it they're
going to find a way the fact
that it was just up until this point
that he was complaining about it after
he had made it open for everyone to look
around
after it had been this way for years
before that where you could still
interact around but you would get the
sign up or login page as default
yes and then today you sent me a tweet
you sent me a tweet in the phone and I
saw that it was embedded and it was
showing up in the in SMS and I was like
oh that's weird and I clicked it and
then I went to it I was like oh now it's
open I don't have to log in or sign up
to see so he keeps going back and forth
he's going back and forth again it's
just to show you it's never about the
Bots it was never about scraping I mean
I was on I was on a Twitter space over
the weekend and I was like I was like
quote me right now I'm telling you this
is not about scraping data this is not
about third party stealing data from
Twitter okay this comes down to Elon
Musk not paying his bill that was due on
June 30th to the Google cloud services
and now they're and they're
trying to either pay up the bill or Port
their stuff over to a new server a new
data center that they have actually
house these servers on and that's what I
believe is happening so when it comes to
this situation they launch on when
Thursday night it was supposed to be
Thursday
and in the first seven hours it's like
10 10 million people yesterday within 24
hours it was 30 million people this
morning when I checked in it was 70
million people had signed up you know
the other thing about that
is that they didn't have much trouble
with signups so Facebook not only are
they capable of launching a website when
there's an opportunity for a dumb
destroying something that millions of
users will use and he's destroying it so
they just like copy it and then they
come over to theirs they're able to
launch it successfully ahead of time and
much cheaper than 44 billion do you know
how much Twitter or do you know how much
meta spent on this is there any numbers
out there anything I have no idea I
can't wait it's an internal it's an
internal wow
it could come out I mean I don't know
how big the team is it's part of
Instagram so I don't know how they said
all right but but I mean but I mean
we'll eventually get estimates of how
much was spent sure because they're a
public trade publicly traded company so
but here's here is here's Tater Daily
News
um says news Twitter is threatening to
Sue Mena over assist quote systematic
willful and unlawful misappropriation of
Twitter's Trade Secrets an IP as well as
scraping them Twitter's data here's that
scraping and a seasoned assist letter
sent yesterday to Zuckerberg by elon's a
lawyer listen you idiot now that
this is the one I want to show you here
he says competition is fine cheating is
not
there's no one that knows more about
stealing someone's ideas
yep then Elon Musk truly this guy people
walk around thinking he invented the
electric car these this is the dumbest
thing I've ever heard of like what are
you doing man if you're gonna sue if
you're gonna Sue meta you have to sue
true social because true social
literally just lifted your entire code
and used your entire code I mean it
looks exactly the same they just changed
the colors a bit right or am I wrong no
about true social it's very very similar
actually there's two posts because since
we're on the topic one of which is
literally that point that I made
um yesterday where my belief is that
again this is not based on copying ideas
this is based on a guy who has a very
weak fragile ego who is unable to admit
that he now has a clunker of a product
that he let totally demolish by removing
80 to 90 percent of the staff not
believing in in supporting the product
but but going Beyond it by platforming
right wing bigots and transphose because
it has been proven with his own child
that Elon Musk is a transphobe okay
there is no doubt about it he's been
public about it his child said look I
don't want anything about it he tweets
about it and then in response is like oh
well you win some you lose some can't
win them all I think is the I think the
actual quote was in in relation to this
was can't win them all which if you're a
parent now I'm not a parent but Tony is
and I'm sure I am people in our audience
are as well but the idea that you are so
willing to go well can't win them all
tells you everything you need to know
about this person who has other children
or is supposed to be this parent of this
child right let me tell you something as
a parent you don't have to agree with
what your kids are doing but you're
still gonna love them like right there's
like even Ted Bundy's Mom okay you know
Ted Bundy runs Ted Bundy's mom still
loved him after she found out what the
he did okay that's unconditional
love that's what that means but when
you're so transphobic that you can't
manage to love your children that's
up here's what you said you said
in a desperate move Elon is suing meta
over threads claiming that they copy
Twitter the fact is Elon doesn't have
the money to take on meta in court and
he knows that if this really was about
copying Elon would have Sue true social
there it is like hello like you they
literally lifted your entire code like
the whole reason the only reason you
could look at gab you could look at
getter you can look at parlor you can
look at any of these other apps that
follow this same model we which is a
micro blogging site that's all it is
there's nothing it's a text-based site
where you say hey this is my update and
my status
Doom send right right it's an art and
it's set up as an archive Twitter is a
is a dumbed down version of Facebook
it's just the wall like you have it
right for people who remember the
original the origins of the wall on
Facebook that's all that it is yeah but
see yesterday is doing you doubted me
yesterday because I said I said the new
threads is like OG Facebook and that's
what I mean I mean it's still it still
is like those uh it
because Facebook's still at its core
it's on OG it's still at its core is
posting it looks like it has a bunch of
other stuff I don't like it it feels
like it feels like I don't know it feels
like we got into a time machine yeah
with the current technology we got in a
time machine and went back like it does
bring up a good question right that is
about
are we really
innovating on on social media
do we really think that we're making it
better and I don't believe that we are
because if you look at these apps
they're all really the same and that's
because of what Twitter had created and
it's microblogging site by being up you
can send this message post it you can do
a photo you can do a video you can make
it very simple and everyone else was
like yeah we'll do the same thing we'll
give you a Bible we'll give you a photo
we'll give you a cover photo we'll give
you a space where you can write your
thoughts you can share these things with
other people you can follow them you can
interact all the sort every one of these
getter parlor Twitter
all of these ones they're all the same
in their basement what's the one with
the stupid one with occupy Democrats
what's that one yeah I'm Gonna Knock on
trial
one sucks
occupy Democrats I just want to say this
real quick yeah occupy Democrats
go ahead go ahead occupy Democrats is
notorious for stealing users content
though they'll cut out the name they
won't attribute them they won't uh they
won't credit them they will take your
content repost it without any sort of
connection to who you are I saw those
things happening yesterday on
threads occupied Democrats was on
threads taking someone's content that I
had seen the day prior on Twitter and
then posting it over there and they even
commented and they said oh man that's a
good post where do you guys come up with
that because they stole it
that's how I occupy Democrats works and
that's how tribal Works in their terms
of service amazing content they steal
your content and they tell you but
nobody reads it that's not to say that
no one else could take your content
right right well here's the thing I'm
technically taking your content on this
show I show it but like when I show your
Tweet even if I don't read the Tweet if
I got it where I'm from even the people
that I hate I still give them
credit like uh here let me show you let
me get an example here's here's a here's
a a tweet about this
um threads by Gabe he says true social
uh send users to email about whining
about thread censoring conservatives DC
lameo you call them they're making up
stories about how it's censoring them
and but see I could go down here
and I could say okay thanks Gabe thanks
for giving us that tweet that's what I
do if you guys see this you guys go like
this sometimes on Twitter I'm giving
Gabe credit for his tweet on my show
right and I say reply thanks make sure
the tweet I showed it on my show so I'm
giving you credit for it sometimes I
show videos like acen and Aaron and I
give them credit but I don't tell you
it's from them I just give them credit
on the platform so that people and see I
tagged it now if I didn't like Gabe
let's say I didn't like it
which may or may not be true then I
would say oh your Tweet sucks your Tweet
sucks so I even give the people who suck
credit for their tweet man I'm not an
I mean I am an but I'm
not that kind of an
so that is why Elon Musk is on here
because he decided that he was going to
sue I saw someone saying bonehead
question mark and we're getting to it
but we're naming we're listening right
musk is the bonehead here there's
there's and the reason that Elon Musk is
one of the boneheads this week that was
in the running is because after
totally just destroying the platform
that he bought and keep in mind all that
Elon had to do
was come in he bought the product right
he brought the service he said I'm
taking Twitter private I'm gonna buy
that up
all he had to do was hire
um just people who had a brain anyway or
just keep attending to just keep the
people who had brains right he already
had they had the people there running it
like they had it and yeah it wasn't
extremely profitable but they were able
to milk profit out of it what the
are you doing CEO they had everyone that
was there they had had a product that
had of marketing it had this and that
they had you know people that were in
charge of safety construction safety
all he had to do
was just keep those things
all you had to do was go be rich that's
all I had to do just go be rich man just
go be really had to do which was
show up and say hey what are you guys
planning to do that sounds great here's
my feedback
I trust you to make these decisions
shows up yeah instead he's like I'll
show up to the board meeting you can
call me if you need me I'll help
transition but other than that it's your
show I'm just here to make sure that
you're successful instead what did you
do he fires 89 of the staff he's getting
rid of head of product head of
engineering he's got ahead of trust and
safety all these people who have nobody
you know knowledge to run the product
they go away and he starts making these
ad hoc decisions and then things start
happening where he doesn't pay the bills
or he doesn't maintain the code or
whatever it might be and falls
apart
was it happening do you want to know
what he did do you want to know what he
did he watched as all these other
right-wing uh social media copycats of
Twitter didn't work he turned Twitter
into that copycat right wing social
media doesn't work and Mark Zuckerberg's
like well we'll just make one that
works and that's the thing that happened
we'll just make one we'll make one
that's done digestible and works and
he'll be the right one parlor suck even
he even said it he was like look they
they Pioneer this not Elon Twitter and
Jack and all of them pioneered this
micro blogging
platform and they set a standard for how
we were for the last
15 years or so really is when they
started or you know 13 years
and when it comes down to it
they missed the mark they weren't able
to keep up and they they've only made a
worse product and we saw
an opportunity here in the market if if
Twitter had maintained itself at what it
was doing Facebook would have never gone
in they would have never said yeah you
know what I think it's time that we put
ourselves in the micro blogging Twitter
like Arena
they would not have done that if Elon
did not the bed because they it
wouldn't be successful because they
watched so many others do it and it
won't work and so now don't work he's
threatening to sue for copying and and
the other other thing that they're
claiming is that he poached Talent which
I just want to correct people if you
fire people
have mass
layoffsies you don't Mark Zuckerberg did
Mark Zuckerberg is like hey you guys
want a job to come build a Twitter over
here like yeah sure all right so so
that's what that's always being said
yesterday but it turns out that the Lord
Also let's just point this out and the
reason that in my tweet I said that Elon
Musk doesn't have the money to take into
court is because Facebook is the largest
social network and the lobbyists and the
legal team that they have will run
circles around anyone who
challenges them the only reason just
look at the history of Facebook and how
Mark Zuckerberg exactly stole it away
from him the only I mean dude Elon Musk
got Winklevoss dude it's like they took
he took the idea and yes I'm I'm
understanding this is a complete copy
for sure now where they take and make
improvements on it is another thing
entirely but when you look at the
situation you can't claim that you
poached Talent when you fired
them and and then bragged about it on
Tucker Carlson and you laughed
about it bragged about it he was firing
people on Twitter
can't claim that obergan poached and on
top of that I found out uh this morning
I was trying to find the article but it
sounds like
um the the talent that was brought on
they weren't actually hiring people
which would have been funny on its own
but it sounds like based on the legal
team in their response to
Twitter's legal team to say we never
hired anyone we never took anyone we
never stole anyone we don't have that I
don't know if it's all people but
they're like we don't have people from
Twitter right there's a whole thing to
be said here is like look we built this
without the team that you fired if
they want to work here go so be it right
yeah hey we'll hire him I mean if anyone
who knows I mean they might have also
said to themselves we're gonna build
this product and we know that we can't
hire because there might be a case made
that there's trade secrets so we can't
hire anyone from Twitter yet but what we
will do is make this clone of it launch
it and then after the fact we'll have
your people on right and they'll fix it
so Kim P here says Twitter screwed up
selling well the shareholders didn't
they may not like Bandits like the
shareholders of Twitter are happy I mean
they had to do with the deal the
fiduciary responsibility of the report
to accept the deal because it was way
more important it was worth way less we
can't not take this deal right because
because Elon tweeted it we would get
replaced and overthrown in the board if
we didn't take that deal right the
amount of money coming in right now
it would be like you owning something
worth a dollar and someone offering you
like a hundred million dollars and
you're like no no thanks yeah you're
like dub this dollar means a lot to me
it's like well you you take it 100 man
we're gonna you're gonna get a hundred
million of them this is what you're
gonna do so it's that's capitalism and
you may not like capitalism that's cool
but it was capitalism baby that's what
it was okay let's let's go to um the
alpha cook
because I talked a little bit about tyd
earlier and it looks like um is it a for
the reason that I I don't know I don't
know is it trans related oh yes yes okay
all right well then I'll let you know
what this is that way yeah no I I I'm
happy to let you I I went off on dyd
earlier because someone in the shoot the
mentioned tyt that I was right
about him because they're just
garbage over there but let's let's watch
this clip from Jank here and let's see
if we can uh
it is
Yank It Jank it off okay ER okay let's
let's listen to shank it off here
[Music]
let's see what he says here
okay and then what I just saw with my
own eyes is not an anecdote you're the
polling Bears it out yeah this is not a
winning issue for us it is what it is
you do what you want with that
information well The Advocates and
activists for the transgender Community
would respond with we don't care about
the politics right we don't care okay
but then they but then no no I gotta say
Let me let me just finish my thought
James okay they'll say that but okay you
don't care about the politics let's just
for once in your life think
strategically about what that means that
means that you're going to continue
pushing the Democratic party to
unequivocally support everything that
the trans activists want even if it's
unpopular among the electorate that
means they're not getting reelected that
means they're going to lose to
Republicans Republican lawmakers who are
passing Draconian disgusting legislation
in various States right now as we speak
against the transgender community so how
does that make you win exactly no that
is incredibly selfish of activists who
are betraying their own Community
because when you say I don't care about
elections who cares about the Democrats
that isn't the point the Republicans
introduced over 600 bills against the
lgbtq community
that's because of Elections and over 70
of them have already passed when you say
I don't care about winning and I don't
care about elections what you're saying
is I'm super selfish leftist activist
and I'd like to build my cloud but
meanwhile I'm willing to throw trans
people in the entire lgbtq Community
under the bus knowing that these bills
are going to pass because we're laser
focused on a losing issue and by the way
you Schmucks you're falling exactly into
the right wing trap the Republicans they
tried everything they tried anti-gay
stuff it didn't work they tried trans
bathrooms you remember that that didn't
work trans King the transgender
Community out of the military that
didn't work they drilled and drilled and
drilled it until they finally found a
little tiny nugget of like hey trans
folks in like competitive Sports seems a
little bit much and you don't engage
them in that fight they lose on
everything else but idiot activists yes
I just called you an idiot Act let's go
in there no I'm going to fall right into
that trap
okay so there's a lot there go ahead go
ahead and I'm just gonna bring up the
fact that so you know I see people in
the chatter he's like oh I agree with
Anna and Jake and stuff like this but
what you have to understand is that this
is also there's also a larger clip that
I don't have at me right now or on me
right now but it comes down to them
criticizing
um trans athletes right a very of again
that we've talked about is a small small
population of a larger Community it's
like point two percent so let me let me
let me back up
because what they're doing in this clip
is claiming that Trump takes the rights
populist stance on this that the popular
stance is that trans athletes shouldn't
be able to compete which is not the
popular stance it's a popular
stance with people in competitive Sports
and people trying to Griff their
supporters what Gabe is saying is that
there are not that many like uh for
instance in Missouri
they were the legislator was trying to
regulate Misha which Misha um just what
what it is in Missouri is the the middle
school and the high school athletes
right the the underage athletes of
Missouri
and because the legislator has the
ability to dictate what Misha does to
some degree
they were trying to legislate that trans
athletes couldn't compete right
we're talking about five
five underage people five right
amongst tens of thousands of underage
athletes the populist stance isn't that
those five people shouldn't compete
right now there may be people who argue
that they shouldn't compete but the
populist stance isn't that they
shouldn't compete that's not the
populist stance and what tyt
and Jake and Anna are doing is is is
using this as their tool to push
transphobia now there is a there is
a not only are they on this trans
athlete thing because trans athletes in
this country are such a small percentage
not just of people but of athletes in
general
but Anna Anna does more transphobia than
just the athlete thing she's
like oh you claim to be a woman you're
not a woman you can't be a woman I'm a
woman and it's a it's a detriment to my
Womanhood
um what is this is this a YouTube link
so it's a it's a longer version this is
this is Benny this is this is Benny so
this is where this all progressed right
this is where this all this all
culminated
where Benny had repeatedly told Jake and
Anna hey the talking points that you're
that you're bringing up on the show The
Narrative that you're pushing is
transphobic and as someone from the
trans Community I don't feel it's the
right way to go about discussing this
issue the way that you talk about it is
not okay you can discuss this without
attacking the community in belittling
and being condescending about it but
also you don't have to be transphobic
about it
so if someone from the trans Community
says hey man your talking points are
phobic they're and
this doesn't it listen what what they're
saying is that if you Ally with trans
people on the trans athlete thing the
Republicans are gonna win you are such a
idiot you are a idiot if
you can't if you can't manage in your
mind to understand that you can Ally
with trans athletes and say yeah they
they should exist yeah they
should compete they should
compete if if they have the
ability to compete just like any other
athlete if they have the ability to
compete should compete
but if you're starting at nope that's
where I draw the line I'm not an ally in
that fight I'm not an ally in that fight
with the Trans Community hears from you
is oh what you want to do is you want to
pick out this one thing and then the
right wing use that one thing to go to
bathrooms because for for Jake and Anna
to say that they're not using this issue
to get to bathrooms and to check
people's genitalia they're passing bills
in Kansas they're passing bills in
Missouri for people to challenge
people's genitalia this has nothing to
do with who's a trans athlete it has to
do with their obsession with the other
people and not the other people not
existing and you tyt and you you
transphobes because you can't get your
head around someone wants to be what
they want to be because that's who they
are you and it's none of
your business it's not jank's
business it's not Anna's business it's
not their business and that's
what Benny's pointing out here okay I'm
done with tyt this latest escalation on
transphobia has just gone too far and I
can't let my presence there seem like a
tactic endorsement of their views
also
laugh my ass off at Anna saying Jesse's
sick signal isn't a transphobe again
this is the slow walk that they do and
what they're doing is trying to convince
you that oh this whole trans thing and
the pride thing again they lump it all
together it's not what you should be
doing and that's that's the the way in
which that tyt is or Jank is trying to
blame trans women for all anti-lgbtq
laws that are passing in red States
seems like that's what that seems like
that's what right-wingers do it seems
like that's what they do but the fact
that he is going in that same narrative
that same talking point is incredibly
malicious and it's dangerous because as
people watch tyt they go
oh yeah you know what I agree with that
as well it only takes one or two of
these populist ideas
that they push forward for you to go
well you know what no they talk about
those things I agree with them on that
or or they say well I agree with them on
most things but it's just this trans
stuff that like uh you know I'm not okay
with
and that's where this wedge is is driven
in
that tyt does right they're always this
oh you have to be this or you have to be
that or they give you some situation
where it's like
um
there they have to be an absolutist
about it it has why this way or or none
at all right you want to see this you
want to see you want to see what I'm
talking about grift you want to see okay
this is Anna's response to Benny
quitting and saying you I'm gone
because of your transphobia this is
Anna's response to it look at the
Chiron at the bottom of the
screen
t-y-t get merch get your
merch get your merch get when I'm
talking about something really
important real important on this show am
I pimping merch no do I yeah because
it's how I make a living here is you
guys supporting us but if you want to
know what the grip machine is doing
here's what the grip machine is doing
get your Progressive merch at shop tyt
not not what the important message is
about what she's about to say okay or
bringing people together winning
elections as Jank claimed again
if you if you listen to that clip that
they just said and you're like well I
agree with all that and I would I would
listen to them then you're not here
hearing what they're saying listen to
what listen to how she misgenders Benny
here even listen
so unfortunately Benny has decided to
leave tyt I am definitely heartbroken
over his her decision to do that I so
unfortunately seems intentional to me it
seems that if you're working with
someone who goes by a certain pronoun
and has you've been working for them
with them for a while
you would know it was uh she and not he
right it's very simple if you're in
constant communication because Benny is
creating content for your network
you would know the way it wasn't like
Benny had just been hired
and she was just making content and was
was just a new employee
she'd been around
and Anna was like he I mean she no it's
a intentional I'm sorry like a a
double take I didn't mean to say that I
said it oh she's a transphoge
and they're using the trans athlete
thing to justify their transphobia
that's all they're doing and if
you buy into it if you buy
into the book because there is a real
actual discussion to have on Athletics
there's a real discussion but it doesn't
start with well I support all trans
people but this issue that's not where
that debate starts with Athletics it
doesn't start there it does not start
there and if you're starting there
you're a transphobe that's what
you are and if and it's okay if you want
to be a trans Vogue hatred and
bigotrys welcome this country as long as
you don't act on it you can hold all the
hatred racism bigotry and
homophobia that you want in transphobia
that you want as long as you don't act
on it but by God don't be trying to
Gaslight us you you
scumbag Turf you you and there's
one one last one last thing I want to
bring up on that if you go to the last
link I sent you this is Jank you know
really really doubling down and and
believing
that because the question the question
was brought up was like what are you
doing about it
here I'll bring it you can read it
so so the original post says why are you
willing to have uh Benny on the main
show to discuss this clear issue with
tyt real progressives are willing to
hear differences grow and learn There's
an opportunity for you to do that too to
which Jank says one she quit so she is
too pure for us which is a
reason and someone who is very like ugh
I don't want to have to deal with that
they clearly aren't willing to listen
and then she and then he says she is an
unhinged person who has called me evil
races and transphobian other endless
insults and lied about our private
conversation wow what a level-headed
person that I could quote unquote learn
from and quote unquote grow by talking
to great idea laughing emoji
regardless of of what might have been
said or wasn't said the he said she said
situation of private conversations
the fact that the immediate response
from Jank is oh well she's too pure for
us and she's unhinged
you're now creating more of a narrative
of this fact that oh this trans person
is unwilling to have a real cordial
logical conversation they're unhinged
they're sick they're they're messed up
in the head that's the same thing that
you hear from Republicans you hear it on
Twitter from people like
Elon you hear from on Twitter
from other Republicans other racist
bigots transload homophobes all of these
people
use that same talking point it's a
mental health thing we just gotta
convert you back to how you should be
you shouldn't do this you shouldn't do
that you shouldn't be you know managing
you shouldn't be you because we're
uncomfortable we are uncomfortable when
you're you and it's an us problem and we
want you to fix you for us you
you and if you if you come in my
comments and talk about how oh well Tony
you're knocking on tyt you goddamn right
I am you ain't right I am and
I'll continue to do it I don't give a
I don't care who tells me to stop
doing it I won't until they
change their so get your
together over there and then I'll
stop talking about it and then
we're gonna move on because I want to
get through the I mean I want to keep
talking about no no no no I I thought I
think we cover it but if yeah
feel free to go to Twitter I'm sure you
can watch that show over there but
I want the audio chance to realize that
the slow walk of what they're doing in
one clip to a next clip to private
interviews because there's plenty of
private images on podcast of Anna being
a whole lot more transphobic I
mean just outright transphobic when
she's not on her show when she's on
someone else's so go search
these clips find it I'm telling you
you're not gonna like her or Jank or tyt
after you see it and really Benny made
the right choice to jump that
ship and get the off that thing
because it's sinking and and the only
reason why it's syncing because it's a
total Griff machine and that's
why they're in the transphobe athlete
because they're trying they're trying to
they're trying to attract the
anti-jobiden crowd to come sell
them merch you dumb that's
what they're doing you stupid bastards
and if you go on their app and realize
that all they are is the Alex Jones of
the left selling all kinds of
out of their store that's just
multi-branded with their on
it you dumb sons of get with it
okay get with it and learn some
sorry Anna okay I'm speaking of
learning some at least stefanik
needs to learn some why is she on
the uh I don't know why she's a designer
at least I need to learn I need to learn
why she's a dishonorable mention so it
recently came up in June this is brought
up but also she came up again recently
um because it came down to
well her connection with moms for
Liberty uh but also it turned out that
in June and this for some reason this
was coming up again uh maybe because of
her support for uh for Trump but it
turns out that at least stefanik was
raising money for herself off of Trump's
indictment and it looked like more news
was coming out about that
um you know Elise stefanik who was
writing the coattails of trump to say
Biden is uh is a crime family and this
and that and and there's
there's so much corruption in the
Democratic Party
what you're seeing is that
it's a bunch of projection like normal
at least stefanik wants to claim that
most recently have had Americans have
had enough of bidenomics Biden's failed
socialist economic policies despite the
fact that those bidenomics those
policies those acts that were passed are
actually improving and helping Americans
today infrastructure you know make it
building back America the fact that we
have to repair and fix the damage that
was done by Reaganomics
is is the very thing that these
Republicans support and want to want to
attack Biden for which is helping their
constituents and nine times out of ten
if not ten times out of ten you find
that these Republicans like Elise
stefanik want to attack
buy it in for these things
or and you find out that they're they're
projecting their own issues or you find
out that they're trying to take credit
for something that Biden did
and so this week
it was mainly the biodynamic stuff that
was coming up but then also there was um
old news of her grifting off of trump
to make money
it's just more of the same right and
especially because at least you know
what's trying to push this idea that oh
what's this cocaine they're all I mean
they're all pushing this thing it's
multiple layers on a lease typically
but one of the other things was about
this whole cocaine thing and there's a
lot but well you know you know the other
thing that I want to bring up about at
least a phonics since she's in the
dishonorable mention here do you know
what school she went to
do you know was it Harvard
she's an elitist yeah she went to
Harvard isn't that funny isn't that
funny is she so she's a supporter of
moms of Liberty too I take it and I I
would imagine that Mom's Liberty would
be very disappointed to know that she's
been indoctrinated into liberal cabal
ways uh at Harvard because we all know
we all know that Harvard is a place of
indoctrination I mean well you got to
remember that all these people who who
yell and and scream about these liberal
leftists Coastal Elites
when they're called out you know
I wouldn't be surprised if their
argument is well you gotta get into the
belly of the Beast to understand how
that machine works you gotta get
knee-deep in that swamp to know how deep
it gets
you know who else at least if phonics
supported you know and I mean then this
is enough to put her on the dishonorable
mention I feel like it's multiple people
actually well right but one person well
multiple personalities right exactly in
particular stands out in my mind is it
is it someone by the name of Oh Boy
George Anthony guitar ravage devolder
zabrovsky Santos that would be the
person that I would say stands out
amongst the other frauds that she has
supported I mean they're all Republicans
so they're all frauds man
they're all frauds so at least
stefanik thanks for making our
dishonorable mention today let's go to
the winner oh man you guys you guys kind
of disappointed me here to be quite
honest uh I know you wanted to go for
the Marge undefeated but she's already
lost twice on the bonehead polls so
she's not undefeated anymore I really
thought it would go to Elon I really did
I thought it would I thought it would
but it didn't went to Marjorie Taylor
green the Madge the Marge the petty
Eddie three toes
Marjorie hookfoot green is our winner of
the week
um I can only guess why this is my guess
is is that it's the little thing
is that is that why she she made it on
the um
yeah because not only did she call uh
Lauren bobert a little because
that's the truth I listen hey I I said
it right well she called Lauren bobert a
little which is the truth and when
you're in the freedom caucus if you tell
the truth apparently they kick you out
you're like oh whoa hey hey easy on the
truth there easy on the truth I'm gonna
I showed this earlier this is from
Patriot takes
um this is uh they put a screenshot of
MTG Battleground her one of her is it
one of her podcasts or the podcast it's
just one of them right one of them I'm
like one completely rebranded the I have
no I have one I have no idea I have no
idea nor do I really give a empty
Battleground her podcast account made
Community notes tag Community notes Here
uh on a daily mail US Post because the
Daily Mail says Marjorie Taylor green
kicked out
of her caucus I mean this would mean
that I should say her caucus it's not
her caucus well yeah I don't know I mean
I mean this would mean this tweet
I don't and I haven't seen this one but
this tweet means that she not only
doubled down by having a semi she had an
interview with the semif with semaphore
then she tripled down during an on-air
interview with Fox News on Sunday uh
this Sunday before last
and then now this would be at this point
she's like it I'm already kicked
out I might as well go full on Falls
deep yeah and this would mean that she
she quadrupled down right on on calling
her a little because she she
posted here on her pod account now I'm
sure there's someone else posting on
this account like our product account we
have people games still up so I have to
assume that it's right well is it it's
her Battleground did you see do you have
the link
to the actual tweet that's the of the
MTG
but she posts Community notes because
what she what they're saying in this is
that Daily Mail is getting this wrong
that uh she called Lauren bobert a
they're getting it wrong
they're it's a little is what she
called her you little which I mean
hey I'm not I'm I'm saying sling the the
words little at Lauren bobert all
you want how I'd use that's
probably a better word for or twatsy
like the mom's of Liberty
um you know Lauren bobert here uh is is
she is she gamma twatsy holy Gammy
Gammy Gammy gamgam Nazi gam gam twatsi
here uh Lauren Lauren bobert is but
Marjorie Taylor green obviously prefers
to call her a little
um which is apparently the reason why
she got kicked out of the freedom caucus
for telling the truth
hmm
what happened
when you tell the truth in the freedom
caucus they kick you out if you say if
you call Matt gants a pedophile they'll
kick you out you telling the truth if
you call Lauren bobert a little
they'll kick you out because you're
telling the truth do not tell the truth
I mean Madison gothorne got kicked out
of the his seat in Congress were telling
the truth about how he'd like to go to
Republican cocaine orgies sex orgies and
we're standing around wondering who the
who the is bringing cocaine
into the White House you goddamn well
know it was a republican 100 oh yeah 100
percent
well now they're trying to say because
the latest development was that it was
it was near the West oh yeah I showed
this one earlier this is Laura Loomer
yeah okay let's play this again I played
this earlier let's listen to Laura
Loomer on Steve Banner's podcast talking
about Marjorie Taylor green Madge
apparently Loomer is a bobert supporter
you know what's funny about that is
bobert several months ago said she would
support the Santos and now Loomer seems
to be
adjacent to I don't know it's weird it's
weird because they don't know who they
support and who they don't it's every
day it changes there's there's some new
dirt because here's here's the thing
yeah all of these people that are out in
the spotlight right now that are in the
Republican Party primary season you know
adjacent whatever you want to call it
each of them have dirt on someone else
and it's only until somebody says
something or you know
speculatively says something
allegedly says something about someone
that they go oh well you know what I
actually have dirt on that person and
let me just drop this nugget out there
and then that person's well I have dirt
on this person and every day it changes
where they're where their their loyalty
stands because they might be with
someone
on one day and the very next day it can
go complete 180 and then the next day
they made up because they're both going
after this other person that was saying
that this other person's supporting a
candidate was you know against or for or
whatever it might be they can't keep it
straight so I mean I can only imagine
how confusing it would be to be a part
of the Republican party and have to know
exactly where your Allegiance your
loyalty stands when all of this
hits the fan because you're like oh well
she did he did they blah blah
I would go probably insane trying to
manage which honestly makes sense if any
of those people have a crazy conspiracy
whiteboard with a bunch of red strings
connecting papers and photos and
clippings and this and that that's
probably how I would have to keep
everything like kind of straight in my
mind because there's no other way I'd be
able to handle it I'd go on a show and
I'd say something and be like oh wait no
and then someone would fact check me or
correct me
and then I'd be like oh that's right
sorry well they did that okay yeah yeah
that's how it would go speaking of
spider webs on the wall let's listen to
Lauren or excuse me Laura loomer's mind
here
just exposed last week as you talked
about on your show uh McCarthy directing
his big donors in California to have
fundraisers for DeSantis I mean what the
hell when is what is Marjorie Taylor
green going to tell her best friend
Kevin McCarthy to endorse her friend
Donald Trump if she's so Mega as she
claims
right in there okay uh
Laura uh where do people where do people
go on your social media to get more of
this even even the walking wart is
speechless here let me ask you
something Gabe have you ever and before
we go
um have you ever seen Laura Loomer and
Kimberly Guilfoyle in the same room have
we ever seen them in the same room I'm
just good that's a good question
I'm just I'm sorry look can we just stop
can you just zoom in or like escape from
the uh the screen and then zoom in on
your mouse
[Music]
um
like she looks she looks like she's a
plastic figurine it's weird like she
she'd probably be part of those pesky
Patriot bobble heads that we found from
from DeSantis well Kimberly Gilmore
looks like AI too I think they're all AI
it's just Nazi AI that's all it is and
Marjorie Taylor green thanks for playing
this week on Bono of the week you're the
winner you're the winner let's give her
her dude
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
he lost
poor Elon lost Elon launched big big
time are you frozen or
the mullet the mullet man the
mullet
oh that's been bonehead of the week
stick around everyone we're gonna have a
few announcements right after this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
minute of the week I love bone end of
the week it's so good it's so good it's
a week and what you should do if you
want to play bone end of the week you
should go follow us on YouTube right now
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube you can go to the community
tab every Thursday and vote for bone of
the week you vote you decide who is the
boner of the week and we break it down
for you in the third hour apparently of
the Tony Michaels podcast every Friday
also you can vote on Twitter right now
at Tony Michaels pod uh we don't know
how long that'll last I'm hoping threads
gets a pull if threads gets a pull I'm
jumping I'm sure they will I they'll get
all of those things in time DM some
other I don't think it pulls also
and speaking of meta and threads follow
us on Facebook at the Tony Michaels at
the Tony Michaels you can watch the show
live there and thank you to everyone who
has resubbed on their Twitch account
with their Amazon Prime account the
directions are at D Tony michaels.com
but you can go to twitch.tv Tony
Michaels you can follow was for free
don't forget to follow us for free but
if you get an Amazon Prime account don't
forget to resub
redo your subscription
um Jay guy four resubbed just a little
bit ago for three months in a row
because to give us the two dollars that
that Amazon gives us you gotta resub
every month it's AAA make you work for
it it happens also download every single
episode in the afternoon on Apple's
Spotify and Google it's free 99 over
there doesn't cost a single thing for
the audio version free free
how do we make a living here uh the
Amazon Prime our patreon accounts which
I know will have some stuff this weekend
um I'm probably doing ask me anything so
go to the Tony michaels.com you can see
my patreon there go to
patreon.commichaels don't forget to
visit us Gabe's Gabe's probably got some
what was that stuff coming I got some
what was that yeah I might I'm I've
gotta do a little uh travel someday next
week okay so you might find me I I'm
gonna see if I can we'll see I don't
know I might make a little weird I might
be in a different location I might be
outside who knows good so go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez says or go
to what was thatshow.com it'll take you
directly to his patreon what was that
show.com that get the newest on the what
was that that's coming up also don't
forget to visit the merch store not the
Tony michaels.com that's store not the
Tony michaels.com get your favorite
merch there we appreciate all your
support you're the best audience in the
world thanks for giving us the vacation
this week it was much needed for me to
get drunk and high I know you don't like
to hear like what were you doing all
week guys I was getting drunk and high
I'm sorry
I don't know what to tell you drunk high
sex drugs and rock and roll that's it
baby don't don't do anything I wouldn't
do this weekend have fun be safe see on
Monday same time same place Surf's Up
you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
them em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon